GOOD MORNING
WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY OF.
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE TODAY
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE- A HEARING.
ON HUMAN TRAFFICKING I'LL BE
EXAMINING THE SCOPE OF THE
PROBLEMS AND THE SOLUTIONS- BUT
BEFORE I GO NGUYEN. TO IT WE
START LITTLE BIT LATE BECAUSE I
HAD A- GAVEL MALFUNCTION WE GOT
THAT TOGETHER- BEFORE YOU GET I
MEAN I'D LIKE TO GO OVER SOME
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS BECAUSE THE
COBIT AND ICAL THE GUIDELINES.
WE ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO
PRVIDE WRITTEN TESTIMONY BEFORE
THE HEARING BY VISITING THECOMMITTEE WEBSITE- A. P. S. F.
DOT A. S. OUT OF A S. S. B. M.
B. L. Y. DOT CA. DOT GOP OF. AS
NOTE THAT ANY WRITTEN TESTIMONY
SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEES
CONSIDER PUBLIC COMMENT AND
MAYBE READ INTO THE RECORD OR
REPRINTED. ALL ARE ENCOURAGED TO
WATCH THE HEARING FROM IT'S A
LIVE STREAM ON THE ASSEMBLY'S
WEBSITE. AT THE SAME- ASSEMBLY
WEBSITE ONLY IS W. W. DOT. A. S.
S. B. M. B. L. Y. DOT CA DOT
GOV. SLASH TODAY- A TWO DAY
EVENT T. O. D. A. Y. S. E. V. E.
N. T. S. THERE WERE ROOM WILL BE
OPEN FOR ATTENDANCE FOR THIS
HEARING ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
ATTENDING. A HEARING WILL NEED
TO WEAR A MASK AT ALL TIMES
WHILE IN THE BUILDING WE
ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO MONITOR
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE FOR
UPDATES AS A RECEIPT WITH THE
WITNESSES AND PUBLIC COMMENT I
WANT TO MAKE SURE EVERYONE
UNDERSTANDS THE ASSEMBLY HAS
RULES TO ENSURE WE MAINTAIN
ORDER. AND RUNNING EFFICIENTLY
FAIR HEARING. THIS WILL NOT BE
TOLERATED TODAY'S AND FORMER
HEARING WILL HAVE PANELISTS BOTH
IN PERSON AND VIA REMOTE
TESTIMONY. EVERY EVERY YEAR AND
I MEAN LIKE EVERY YEAR MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATURE INTRODUCED
SEVERAL BILLS AIMED AT
PREVENTING HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND
MOST OF WHICH ARE HURT BY THIS
COMMITTEE I'M GLAD TO SEE SO
MANY WORKING TO ADDRESS THIS
COMPLEX PROBLEM HOWEVER I FELT
IT WAS IMPORTANT TO HAVE AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING TO ADVANCE
THE COMMITTEES KNOWLEDGE ON
HUMAN TRAFFIC. SO THAT WE CAN
WORK TOGETHER TO PASS EFFECTIVE
EVIDENCE INFORMED ANTI TRUMP
TRAFFICKING LEGISLATION AT THIS
IS AN INFORMAL HEARING THE
COMMITTEE WILL NOT BE VOTING ON
ANY LEGISLATION TODAY. THROUGH
THE TESTIMONY WE HEAR TODAY I
HOPE THAT WE WILL ALL BE PISSED
HEARING WITH A GREATER
UNDERSTANDING OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IN CALIFORNIA. AND
WHAT WE CAN DO AS POLICYMAKERS
TO EFFECTIVELY PREVENT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND HELP. THE
VICTIMS WHO SURVIVE IT. WE HAVE
FOUR PANELS TODAY CONSISTING OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT. LEGAL EXPERTS
ANTI TRAFFICKING ADVOCATES
ACADEMICS AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS
WHO WILL ADDRESS A BROAD
SPECTRUM OF TRAFFICKING ISSUES
OUR FIRST PANELIST JOHN MARSH
CHIEF OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
DIVISION OF LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WILL GIVE A PRESENTATION ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE'S EFFORTS
TO COMBAT HUMAN TRAFFICKING
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE'S HUMAN
TRAFFICKING TASK FORCE WILL BE
AVAILABLE FOR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS IF NEEDED. DURING OUR
SECOND PANEL WILL HEAR FROM TINA
RODRIGUEZ AND ANDREA GRIFFIN WHO
WILL SHARE THEIR RESPECTIVE
EXPERIENCES AS SURVIVORS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING. THEY WOULD
TALK ABOUT THE BARRIERS RISON
COUNTER ASSESSING VICTIM
SERVICES. I NEED FOR A VICTIM
CENTERED AND TRAUMA INFORMED
APPROACH TO HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
JOIN OUR SECOND PANEL THE
SABRINA TOLU. TOLU THEIR-
DIRECTOR OF FEDERAL POLICY AT
LOYOLA LAW SCHOOL'S SENATOR
JAMES. ATTY TRAFFICKING POLICY
INITIATIVE SABRINA DAHLE LUGAR
HELLO THERE I'LL. GET IT BY THE
END OF THIS. REALLY OF THE- WITH
SERVE HEARING WILL SPEAK TO THE
CRIMINALS. AND READ THE IS OF
TRAF PERSONS THE NEXT PANEL IS
NATALIE MAC CHIEF DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
CALIFORNIA VICTIM COMPENSATION
BOARD. IN TWENTY NINETEEN TO
LEGISLATURE PASSED AB SIX TO
NINE WITH AUTHORIZED THE BOARD
TO PROVIDE COMPENSATION FOR LOSS
OF INCOME. TO VICTIMS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING NATALIE MAC WILL
PROVIDE THE COMMITTEE WITH AN
UPDATE ON THE BOARD'S
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB SIX TO
NINE. AND THE BOARDS. APRISTA
AWARENESS ABOUT THE PROGRAM IT'S
A WALKER DEPUTY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CALVI CP. WILL ALSO
BE AVAILABLE TO ANSWER TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS IF NEEDED. FINALLY A
FOURTH PANEL IS COMPRISED OF
SEVERAL INDIVIDUALS INCLUDING OF
MARINE MCLEAN. WHO WILL GIVE A
PRESENTATION ON U. S. THE
INTERNATIONAL HUMAN RIGHTS
CLINICS TWENTY TWENTY ONE REPORT
ON THE OVER POLICING OF SEX
TRAFFICKING. DOES THE BILL
BELAYER- VILELA DIRECTOR OF
STATE POLICY AND LOCAL LAW
SCHOOLS AT THE GIVES YOU NEEDED
JANE AT THE TRAFFICKING POLICY
INITIATIVE WHO SPEAK TO
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EXISTING
STATEWIDE HUMAN TRAFFICKING
PREVENTION PROGRAMS. PROFESSOR
STEPHANIE RICHARD ADVISER FOR A
LOYAL. LOYAL LOS CRUZ ANTI
TRAFFIC INITIATIVE ON THE ROLE
OF EMPLOYERS. AND PREVENTION OF
LABOR TRAFFICKING AND LASTLY
COMMISSIONER CYNTHIA BROUGH
WEEZER OF THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION WHO WILL DISCUSS THE
NEED FOR COORDINATION AMONG
STATE AND LOCAL LABOR
TRAFFICKING PREVENTION EFFORTS.
I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
TESTIMONY FROM OUR PANEL OF
WITNESSES. VERY FULL AGENDA
TODAY I ALSO ASK THAT YOU USE
YOUR TIME JUDICIOUSLY SO THAT WE
HAVE SUFFICIENT OPPORTUNITY. FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END. WITH
THAT I INVITE MEMBERS- FROM THE
COMMITTEE IF THEY WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK I SEE WE HAVE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CLERK AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS SHE GOT TO HEAR ANYONE
IF YOU WANT. TO HAVE ANY OPENING
STATEMENT. OKAY THEN LET'S BE
WITH OUR FIRST PANEL TO DO NEED
TO TAKE ROLE. NOT NO OKAY SO
WE'LL BEGIN WITH OUR FIRST
PANEL- PRESENTATION OF THE
ATTORNEY JOBS EFFORTS TO COMBAT
HUMAN TRAFFICKING- JOHN MARSH
CHIEF OF DIVISION OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE OFFICE OF
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL. I DON'T
SEE HIM IN A ROOM SO YOU MUST BE
BY THE VARIOUS CM NOW. YOU
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY MISTER
MARSH YOU MAY BEGIN. AND YOU
HAVE MINUTES. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- IT'S GREAT SEEING YOU IN
THANKS TO THE MEMBERS FOR
INVITING US TO TALK ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE. I'D LIKE TO
START OFF JUST GIVING SOME
BACKGROUND- ABOUT TRAFFICKING IN
CALIFORNIA SO CALIFORNIA HAS THE
HIGHEST HUMAN TRAFFICKING RATE
WITHIN THE UNITED STATES
ARGUMENT DRAFTING TEAMS HAVE
FOUND. DOCTORS USE MANY
DIFFERENT TACTICS TO RECRUIT AND
RETAIN THEIR VICTIMS INCLUDING
FORCIBLE PARTICIPATION AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL MANIPULATION.
ORGANIZED CRIMINAL ENTERPRISES
UTILIZE SEX WORKERS VICTIMS AND
TYPICALLY PUT THEM ON A TEN DAY
CIRCUIT WE FOUND THAT- THROUGH
CALIFORNIA- VICTIMS ARE PUT INTO
A BRAWL HOLES OR. STRONG PARLORS
AN ATTENDEE CIRCUIT DON'T START
IN SACRAMENTO MOVED THROUGH
COMMERCIAL- BUILDINGS TO
RESIDENTIAL AREAS- THROUGHOUT
THE AREA AND THE MOVE TO
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE STATE AND
THEN PUT THROUGH ANOTHER TEN DAY
CIRCUIT I MOVED TO DIFFERENT
PARTS OF THE STATE MAKING-
IDENTIFICATION DIFFICULT FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT- WE'VE SEEN THAT-
MASSAGE PARLORS AND BROTHELS.
ABOUT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
BOTH LARGE CITIES- COMMERCIAL
BUILDINGS RESIDENTIAL LOCATIONS-
TRAFFICKERS OF JUVENILES IN THE
SAN DIEGO AREA HAS GONE UP 33%
OVER THE LAST YEAR. RECEIVE
CORRELATIONS POSSIBLY- TO COPE
WITH- BUT PEOPLE ARE HOME MORE
IN- UTILIZING- VICTIMIZING YOUNG
PEOPLE. SO LET ME EXPLAIN WHAT
DOJ'S CURRENTLY DOING AND- OUR
ROLE WITHIN WITHIN THE SPACE OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING IN SOME AREAS
THAT WERE FOCUSING ON. SO THE
DIVISION OF LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS
TO IDENTIFY HUMAN TRAFFICKING
TEAMS WHICH WE REFUNDED FOR- WE
ALSO HAVE A TASK FORCE IN THE
SAN DIEGO AREA. OUR HUMAN
TRAFFICKING JAMES TAKE A
THREEFOLD APPROACH. TO SEX
TRAFFICKING FOCUSING ON SEX
TRAFFICKING MASSAGE PARLORS
MARSHALL AND RESIDENTIAL
BROTHELS. LABOR TRAFFICKING. IN
HOME CARE FACILITIES CANNABIS
CULTIVATION AND RESTAURANTS AND
THIRDLY EXPEDITORS FOCUSING ON
TWO NINETY MONITORING IN. TWO
EIGHT- TO EIGHTY EIGHT UNDER
COVER OPERATIONS. ANOTHER HUMAN
TRAFFIC- RESPONSE SCHEME AS
IDENTIFIED IN FOCUSING ON
RECOVERING THE VICTIMS FROM
HUMAN TRAFFICKING- WE UTILIZE A
FOUR P. MODEL. FOCUSING ON
PREVENTION- BEFORE TO CURSE
PROTECTION USING A TRAUMA
INFORMED APPROACH. PROSECUTION
ENCOURAGING PROSECUTION
PROSECUTORS TO CHARGE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND HELPING WITH THE
COMPLEXITY OF THOSE CASES. IN
PARTNERSHIP WE ENCOURAGE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS TO
PARTICIPATE WITH OUR TEAMS. BUT
WE ALSO FOCUS ON EXPOSING THESE
TYPES OF CRIMINAL ACTIVITY AND
TRYING TO BRING IT INTO PLAIN
SIGHT. WE FOCUS ON- WORKING WITH
VICTIM SERVICES- WE FOCUS ON
GETTING THE STEPS LEADS. I'M NOT
A LOT OF SURVEILLANCE OPERATIONS
- WE WORK WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND OTHER STATE
AGENCIES AND FEDERAL AGENCIES TO
TRY TO EXPOSE. THIS.
UNDERGROUND- WORK. WE ALSO HAVE
A CRIMINAL LAW DIVISION- WITH
PROSECUTORS ASSIGNED FROM OUR
SPECIAL PROSECUTIONS SECTION OF
THAT SUPPORT DELES HUMAN
TRAFFICKING JAMES BUT ALSO
SUPPORT LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
DURING HUMAN TRAFFICKING
INVESTIGATIONS. FILE CHARGES
AGAINST SEX AND LABOR
TRAFFICKERS CRIMINAL ALSO
MAINTAINS A STATEWIDE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING COORDINATOR PROTEST
A PAGE IN PUBLIC OUTREACH SERVES
AS A LEGAL EXPERT UP FOR THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S IN IS A RESOURCE AND
POINT OF CONTACT FOR OUR
INVESTIGATORS. INVESTIGATORS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ELEVEN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMERCIAL HE
SEXUALLY EXPLOITED CHILDREN
ACTION TEAM. SO GIVE ME AN IDEA
I SPOKE ABOUT- DOJ STOPS
FLOORSTANDING THE SAN DIEGO
AREA. BOB HE MANAGEMENT AND
SUPERVISION OF THE TASK FORCE
AND NOT CELLS FORCE WORKS WITH
SIXTEEN. THE INDIVIDUAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT PARTNERS SO IT IS A
LARGE TASK FORCE MEMBERS OF THE
SAN DIEGO- BEAR BAY AREA- WE UP
WE ALSO HAVE TO HUMAN
TRAFFICKING TEAMS ONE LOCATED IN
SACRAMENTO AND THE SECOND
LOCATED IN FRESNO AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. OUR STATEWIDE
ENFORCEMENT MODEL IS TO DISRUPT
AND DISMANTLE HUMAN TRAFFICKING
AND CHILD EXPLOITATION. WE DO
THIS THROUGH A JURISDICTIONAL
HUMAN TRAFFICKING CASES. AND
FOCUS ON NOT ONLY ENFORCEMENT OR
PROSECUTION- PROSECUTION AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE CASES- INVOLVED
IN INTELLIGENCE SHARING WITH
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND ARTISTIC
GATORS- WE'LL GET SOME OF THESE
CRIMES SPECIFICALLY BUT WHAT WE
FOUND IS A LOT OF OUR OTHER
TEAMS UP FOR X. AND Y. Y. COLOR
TEAM FOR SPECIAL OPERATIONS TEAM
ARE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY G. ARE
RUNNING INTO HUMAN TRAFFICKING
IN THEIR INVESTIGATIONS THAT
DON'T NECESSARILY SPECIFICALLY
START OFF AS A HUMAN TRAFFICKING
INVESTIGATION. SO SOME OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT THAT WE'VE SEEN-
SMALL AND MEDIUM SIZED POLICE
AGENCIES DON'T. STAFFING. TO
CONDUCT THESE INVESTIGATIONS.
OKAY CAN COME AND HELP BUT A LOT
OF TIMES THESE TYPES OF
INVESTIGATIONS GO ON WORKED UP
BECAUSE THEY ARE VERY LABOR
INTENSIVE THEY TAKE SURVEILLANCE
THEY TAKE A LONG TERM
INVESTIGATIONS THEY TAKE.
TECHNOLOGY. I THESE TYPES OF
INVESTING. THE DAYS OF BEING
ABLE TO KNOW US ST WHERE VICTIMS
WERE PUT OUT ON THE STREET AND
THE TRAFFICKERS WERE STANDING
ACROSS THE STREET ARE OVER PAGE
NOT IN PLAIN VIEW ANYMORE IT'S
DIFFICULT. THE USE OF TECHNOLOGY. AND SOCIAL- INTERNET PLATFORMS
AND SOCIAL MEDIA. IS WHERE UP
THIS EXISTS AND THANK GEHRY
INTO- SERVICES DIFFICULT FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TAKES. THE EXPERTISE
AND- THAT TIME TO WORK THESE
LONG TERM INVESTIGATIONS. WELL
WE NEED MORE EDUCATION FOR LOCAL
BUSINESSES WERE CONSTANTLY
PUTTING ON TRAINING FOR
BUSINESSES TO HELP IDENTIFY
VICTIMS AND- PEOPLE THAT ARE
INVOLVED IN THIS TYPE OF WORK-
WE FOUND LANGUAGE ISSUES- AND
PENDING ON THE GEOGRAPHICAL.
LOCATION AND- WHERE THE VICTIMS
ARE FROM BUT- COUNTRY AND DON'T
KNOW HOW TO. AVIGATE AND
THERE'S A DISTRUST OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND NOT KNOWING
WHERE TO GO- IN THE SITUATIONS.
THE FEAR OF INTIMIDATION.
TRAFFICKERS OF GETTING IT NOT
ONLY BY THE TRAFFICKER BUT
PEOPLE INVOLVED IN THE
PROSECUTION RATE EMPLOYERS
HOLDINGS- WORKERS LOST STAGE
THREATENING DEPORTATION THROUGH
FEAR OR INTIMIDATION- EMPLOYER
STILL. HOLDING WAGES BACK. FOR
WORKERS AND GIVING LOWER OR NO
WAY NO OVERT NOTE OFF- I THINK
YOU CAN DISCARD AS WE FOUND
VICTIMS WERE PROBLEM. VERSIONS
OF THE PROS. AND ONCE. IT'S FOR-
THERE DROP OFF IN IT UNKNOWN
OKAY. IN ONLY MINIMAL MONEY OR
NO MONEY COMES TO PAY FOR THESE
PEOPLE THAT APARTMENTS INTENDED-
THIS MARIJUANA GROWS. ANOTHER
SOLUTIONS- IT'S EASY TO TALK
ABOUT SOME OF THE PROBLEMS BUT
BUT DOJ'S FOCUSED ON- SOLUTIONS
- MORE PERSONNEL MORE STAFF-
ALWAYS HELPS. WE WANT TO FOCUS
ON THE FORENSICS- OF THESE CASES
WELL WITH THE HELP OF SOME
FINANCIAL AUDITORS AND
INTELLIGENCE STAFF THIS CAN
CAUSE THIS CAN HELP MAKE THIS
THING TOGETHER OTHERS THERE'S A
LOT OF TASK FORCES. THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WORKING
IN THIS AREA BUT THERE'S NOT A
LOT OF STATE CONNECTIVITY- AND
WE COULD DO BETTER IN THIS SPACE
. WE WANT TO ATTACK OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. FROM ALL ALL
DIFFERENT AREAS BUT WHAT WE
FOUND IS. IT'S IN ALL DIFFERENT
AREAS WE'VE SEEN IT IN GAMES- WE
SEE THE VIOLENCE WE SEE-
ORGANIZED CRIMINAL. ENTERPRISES
WORKING IN THE SPACE- WE NEED
THE OJ YOU WOULD LIKE MORE MONEY
FOR CREATING COSTS WHEN WE
STARTED OUR TWO TASK FORCES THEY
WERE FOCUSED ON. ALLEN STAFFING
ENTER OUR INVESTIGATIONS WE
FOUND- BUT THERE'S A LOT MORE
EXPENSES TO DOING THESE TYPES OF
INVESTIGATIONS- WE ALSO. GET
MORE HELP ON- VICTIM SERVICES
OUR TASK FORCES WERE CREATED
WITH WITH PERSONNEL COSTS BUT-
NOT COST. SERVICES AND WE'VE
SEEN THAT- DOJ COULD DO MORE-
ENOUGH SPACE- OPEC DUMPS- AND
THEN CREATE INCREASED
COLLABORATION WITH NONPROFITS WE
SPEND A LOT OF TIME- MAKING
CONNECTIONS AND WORKING- WITH
NGOS BUT THIS ISN'T ALWAYS AN
AREA OF IMPROVEMENT AND I KNOW
IT- WHEN YOU HEAR FROM- NGOS
LATER THEY'RE GONNA- WHAT THE
SAME COLLABORATION SO IT'SSOMETHING THAT- EVERYBODY IS
WORKING TOWARDS A BOOK BUT WE
WOULD LIKE TO FOCUS MORE- I
WOULD LIKE TO. JUST KIND OF GIVE
AN EXAMPLE OF. A CASE THAT- HERE
J. WAS WORKING ON IT AND IT
WASN'T SPECIFICALLY. A HERE
AGAIN START AS A HUMAN
TRAFFICKING CASE IT WAS OUR
SPECIAL OPERATIONS TEAM THAT WAS
FOCUSED ON VIOLENT CRIME AND
GANGS. M. WHEN THE INVESTIGATION
STARTED THE LOCAL AGENCY THAT WE
ARE ASSISTING. DO THAT- OTHER
HELLO AGAIN PROBLEMS THE GAME
WAS VERY VIOLENT. BUT DID NOT
KNOW OR- AN ASSUMPTION OF HOW
THE GAME WAS- GETTING RESOURCES
TO. I MET- I WOULD ACTIONS AND
AT PAPER PAPER GUNS AND SUPPLY
THEIR GANG MEMBERS AND- DURING
THE DURING THE INVESTIGATION WE
DETERMINED THAT THE GAME WAS-
WORKING. SEX TRAFFICKING THEY
WERE SENDING OF THEIR VICTIMS
THROUGHOUT THE NATION THIS WAS A
SMALL- GANG IN IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND THEY WEREN'T EVEN OFF
PUTTING THEIR VICTIMS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY THEY WERE SENDING
HIM TO LOS ANGELES TO SAN DIEGO
TO NEBRASKA- TO TEXAS ALL OVER
THE UNITED STATES AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAD NO IDEA THAT
THIS ACTIVITY WAS GOING ON
BECAUSE IT WASN'T HAPPENING. IN
THEIR SPECIFIC AREA- WE WERE
ABLE TO TAKE DOWN THE
INVESTIGATION TAKE DOWN THIS
CRIMINAL ORGANIZATION YEAH AND
IT RAN A LOT OF VIOLENT ACTION
IN A NOT ONLY AN ACTIVITY. BUT
THE- BEGINNING WAS USING SEX
TRAFFICKING JUST SUPPORT OTHER
ACTIVITIES. IN THE GAMES. SO I
POINT THAT OUT- JUST AS AN
EXAMPLE OF HOW THIS ACTIVITY.
ISN'T IN PLAIN VIEW ANYMORE IT
DOESN'T SPECIFICALLY STAYING IN
GEOGRAPHICAL AREAS. SO THE PAIR
. OR LAW ENFORCEMENT. THAT'S WHY
IN AREAS HAVE YOU CAN IDENTIFY.
THESE ISSUES. I BELIEVE THAT CAN
BE SENT OVER- ACTION QUESTIONS
AND I JUST LIKE TO TAKE SOME
TIME TO ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS.
FOR YOU- ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
WAS WHAT WHAT IS THE OKAY DOING
TO COLLABORATE WITH. WITH LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT ANOTHER HUMAN
TRAFFICKING- TEAMS SO. YES-
CONSTANTLY WORKING WITH LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND OTHER TEAMS
TO TRY TO SHARE INFORMATION
THROUGHOUT THE STATE A DOJ
PARTICIPATES. IN SWEEPS- HELPS
LOCAL AGENCIES. IDENTIFY THE
PROBLEMS EIGHT THE NEXT LOCAL
AGENCIES- WITH CITY WIDE
INFORMATION. ANOTHER QUESTION
IS- WHAT IS A DOJ DOING- FOR THE
VICTIMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
ARMANEN JUSTICE IS VERY FOCUSED
ON OUR PARTNERSHIPS WITH NGOS-
WE STAY CONNECTED TO LOCAL
SERVICES THROUGHOUT THE STATE-
AND THAT IS ONE OF THE BENEFITS
OF HAVING A STATE AGENCY. IN
THIS SPACE WE HAVE CONNECTIVITY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND WE CAN
HELP. LOCAL AGENCY. BURKE GOOD
ORAL. WILL COMMISSIONS. I'M
SORRY- OKAY LOCAL AGENCIES TO
SERVICES THROUGHOUT THE STATE-
ANOTHER QUESTION WAS- THIS DOJ-
CURRENTLY PER RECOMMENDATIONS
REGARD THE PREVENTION OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING SINCE THE DISCLOSURE
OF THE TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
REPORT- TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
REPORT- FOCUSED ON PROMOTE GREEN
SUPPLY CHAINS STRENGTHENED
RESTRICTIONS A STATE CONTRACTORS
IN INCREASED PUBLIC AWARENESS-
YOUR J. SPECIFICALLY. HAS
FOCUSED ON THOSE AREAS- WE'RE
STARTING- WITH ARE YOU IN
GRAMMAR SCHOOL AREAS TO-
CONTINUE TO- PROMOTE AWARENESS.
IN THIS AREA AND WORK ON-
GETTING BETTER AT-
INVESTIGATIONS BASED WITH A
COMPLETE COMPUTER FORENSICS AND
UTILIZING. A PAST TRAINING OF
OUR OUR PERSONNEL. AND THEN THE
LAST QUESTION WAS WELL AS BUDGET
CONCERNS IN. A NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL BUDGETS- SO FIRST
INVESTIGATION IN IN IN PERSONNEL
TECHNOLOGY AND ADVANCED
TRAINING- I WOULD BE
SPECIFICALLY FOR DOJ- WE COULD
INCREASE IN THOSE AREAS ANOTHER
AREA YES I SPOKE ABOUT EARLIER
THIS EDUCATION AND OUTREACH TO
THE COMMUNITY. WELL WE ARE
CONSTANTLY OUT AT BUSINESSES AND
HOTELS BUT I'M NOT ONLY
BUSINESSES BUT- COUNTY BOARD
SUPERVISORS AND CITY COUNCILS
AND- TRYING TO EXPLAIN THE
ISSUES AND THEN SCHOOLS. IN A
RESOURCE SERVICES. I AND ALLOW.
YOUR BUDGET ATHLETIC YOU BUDGET
I BUT IT AREA THE DOJ VERY POOR
ON HIS VICTIMS. WE WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE MORE OF A VICTIM STERN
WHICH IN. FOR VICTIMS AND IT'S
OUR OUR CAPACITY. TO MORE SERVE
. WERE VICTIMS- THOSE AREAS
THAT- NOT ONLY I WANTED TO POINT
OUT BUT SOME QUESTIONS THAT CAME
FROM THE BOARD AND OPEN TO ANY
QUESTIONS YEAH I WAS REMISS TO
INTRODUCE. US TO THE PARISH IS A
SPECIAL AGENT IN CHARGE OF OUR
HUMAN TRAFFICKING TEAMS HERE
PARTMINER JUSTICE SO WE GET INTO
ANY READING- KEY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS REGARDING OPERATIONS
OR WORK OUR TEAMS- SHE'S HERE
AT- INJURY QUESTIONS ALSO. THANK
YOU NUMBER NOW JOIN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BRIAN ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
AND ARE PRICED YEAR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LACKEY- I HAVE TWO
QUESTIONS THE COULD BE QUICK BUT
I'VE A FEELING THEY WON'T BE
QUICK. ON THE ON THE- UNDER
DISCUSSION ABOUT BUDGET AND WHAT
DO G. NEEDS TO DOJ NEEDS TO JUST
TAKE THIS TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
SPECIA AND REALLY CARES ABOUT
THE TECHNOLOGY. AND THE- WHAT
I'M HEARING ABOUT ORGANIZED.
CRIMINAL ENTERPRISES. DATA DATA
ACTUALLY DUSTER DO BUSINESS
MODELS. YOU SELL DRUGS YOU SELL
THE DRUG YOU CAN'T USE ANYMORE
BUT WITH HUMAN TRAFFICKING IT'S
A COMMODITY THAT YOU CAN USE
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN TO
MAKE MONEY. AND SO THAT NEW
BUSINESS MODEL IS STARTING TO
INFILTRATE NOT ONLY GAMES BUT
THE CRIMINAL ELEMENT IS USING IT
SO ONE- ON THE BUDGET ASPECT-
WHAT COMES TO. A GOOD EXAMPLE
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT SMASH AND
GRAB- MMHM YOU KNOW I HAD A BILL
FOR THAT. MUCH TO MY SURPRISE
AND VERY. VERY HAPPY THE
GOVERNOR PUT IN TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS INTO
THE BUDGET TO COMBAT THAT. COULD
BE MADE THAT A PRIORITY AND WE
PUT IT IN THERE. SO I WOULD LIKE
A BUDGET NUMBER. FOR HOW DO WE
COMBAT I'M HUMAN TRAFFICKING
YEAR YOU SAY YOU NEED BUDGET BUT
I NEED A NUMBER CAN YOU GIVE ME
A NUMBER RIGHT NOW TODAY THIS
MINUTE. WHAT DO YOU NEED TO GO
BACK. IN THE CONTEXT OF. WE
APPROVED TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS. DEAL WITH
SMASH AND GRAB WELL THAT IS VERY
DISTURBING. AND IT IS A IT IS A
PROBLEM AND IT SCARES THE HECK
OUT OF PEOPLE. FROM A HUMAN.
STANDPOINT HUMAN TRAFFICKING I
THINK RATES MUCH HIGHER THAN
THAT. AND THAT WE REALLY NEED
TO- TO PUT ALL THE RESOURCES
THEY DOT HAS. INTERCEPTED AT
THAT'S ONE QUESTION THE SECOND
QUESTION IS ABOUT LEGISLATION.
ANY ORGANIZED RETAIL THE- WE
WENT AFTER AND IS THIS BODY
APPROVED WE WENT AFTER
INCREASING PENALTIES. ON THE
ORGANIZERS NOT THE VICTIMS. NOT
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE PARTICIPATING
IN ANY ACTIVITY WE TRY TO DO OFF
RAMPS AND DO THINGS THAT THEY
HELP THEM. BUT THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE ORGANIZING IT WE EFFECTIVELY
MADE IT. HARDER FOR THEM TO GET
BACK OUT AGAIN TO CREATE THAT
CRIMINAL ENTERPRISE AGAIN AND
AGAIN AND AGAIN. ARE THE THINGS
THAT WE CAN DO. TO GET TO THE-
BASICALLY THE RINGLEADERS OF ALL
THIS SO THAT- WE CAN GET THEM
OFF THE STREET AND IN A WAY FOR
THOSE RIGHT. TWO DIFFERENT
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU FOR THOSE
QUESTIONS- VERY THOUGHTFUL IN IT
AND PURCHASE IT- AND IN A HURRY
NOT I WANT TO BE EQUALLY
ESTOPPEL THE BUDGET ASK- I WOULD
I WOULD DEFINITELY LIKE TO AND
PROVIDE OPTIONS- IN ORDER. WE DO
ALWAYS BEEN TOPPLED A PROVIDING
OPTIONS I KNOW IN SOME OTHER
ASKS WE BROUGHT BEFORE YOU TO
GIVE YOU DIFFERENT LEVELS AND TO
GIVE YOU AN IDEA OF WHAT.
RESOURCES WOULD BE USED FOR NOT
ONLY USE FOR YOU KNOW I WOULD
BRING IN THE REST OF THE STATE
AND I THINK THAT'S- A REALLY
IMPORTANT IMPORTANT PART OF
TACKLING THIS PROBLEM IT IN YOU
KNOW CHASE ALWAYS. BEEN A
LEADER. IN ORGANIZING AND
BRINGING IN COLLABORATING WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT SO I WILL COME
BACK TO YOU WITH A THOUGHTFUL
BUDGET ASK SOMETHING THAT MAKES
SENSE BUT NOT ONLY ONE. SEVERAL
OPTIONS. CREATE MORE DISCUSSION
ABOUT HOW TO APPROVE WITH
APPROPRIATELY ATTACK THIS ISSUE
AND I KNOW THERE ARE SOME GREAT
SPEAKERS COMING UP AFTER ME-
THAT I'D LOVE TO COLLABORATE
WITH ALSO IN COMING UP WITH
THIS- BUDGET APPS US ABOUT WILL
BE SOMETHING THAT THAT ALL
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU. I ALSO ONE
HUNDRED ORGANIZER'S- THAT IS J.
FOCUS. OUR FOCUS IS THE
VICTIM'S- AND GETTING THEM THE
SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED. BUT OUR
SPECIALTY AS FOCUS ON HIGH LEVEL
INVESTIGATIONS AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR WE'RE LOOKING
AT TAKING DOWN. WE'RE LOOKING AT
. PEOPLE THAT ARE OUR BENEFITING
FINANCIALLY FROM THESE RESOURCES
THAT'S WHY I JUST EXPECTED TO BE
ABLE TO GIVE ABOUT GAINING IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY BECAUSE LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT I HAVE NO IDEA
HOW THEY WERE MAKING SO MUCH
MONEY THEY WEREN'T EVEN INVOLVED
THEIR NARCOTICS. DEALING ANYMORE
BECAUSE IT BROUGHT TOO MUCH
ATTENTION TO THEM LOCAL
AREA AND LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
WAS PERPLEXED ON HOW MUCH MONEY
HE'S GETTING LEADERS WERE MAKING
THEY WERE DRIVING AROUND AND-
ENERGY WAGONS THROUGH THE
CENTRAL VALLEY THEY HAD NO IDEA
BUT THAT JUST GIVES YOU A SMALL
GLIMPSE OF THE FINANCIAL
COMPONENT TO THIS. SO OUR GOAL
IS TO FOCUS ON ENTERPRISES IS IN
PEOPLE THAT ARE ORCHESTRATING
THIS THIS. TYPE OF CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY. ESPARTO IMPAIR.
THERE'S ALWAYS A RESTORE- TO TRY
TO WORK ON THOSE ISSUES AS A
GROUP. THANK YOU AND MISTER CORK
AS A QUESTION YUP WE DON'T HAVE-A LOT O TIME SO I'LL JUST MAKE
A SHORT STATEMENT- THE
UNFORTUNATE PART OF THIS
DISCUSSION IS 80% OF IT WAS
SPENT ON SEX TRAFFICKING. AND
SEX TRAFFICKING IS THE EASIEST
THING FOR ENFORCEMENT TO DO
BECAUSE IT'S OUT IN THE OPEN.
BUT 80% OF THE PROBLEM IS REALLY
LABOR TRAFFICKING. AND THERE'S
REALLY FROM WHAT I CAN TELL NOT
A BIG EFFORT THERE. SO- OFTEN
IT'S HIDDEN IT'S A MADE TO
DOESN'T HAVE PAPERS AND WORKS
EIGHTEEN HOURS A DAY SEVEN DAYS
A WEEK FOR NO PAY. AND IT'S
SOMETHING WHICH IS NOT SPENDING
ENOUGH TIME ON. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
HELLO ALLOWED THE OTHER MEMBERS
TODAY ONE ANY OPENING ANY
OPENING COMMENTS MISTER BRYANT
REFLECT THE- THEY WANT TO MAKE
IT. A GOOD. WELL JUST STATE THE
OBVIOUS THAT THIS IS A- THIS IS
A BIG SCOURGE FOR OUR SOCIETY
TODAY AND I DON'T THINK ANY OF
US UP HERE HAVE AN IDEA AS TO
HOW. PROLIFIC AND HOW- UGLY.
THIS PROBLEM REALLY IS I MEAN
AND IT'S NOT JUST IN. IN THE
URBAN ENVIRONMENT EITHER IT IT'S
ALL OVER AND- WE HAVE SOME VERY
SOPHISTICATED OPERATIONS THAT
ARE TAKING PLACE AND SO I'M I'M
HAPPY TO HEAR THE DOJ'S
PARTNERING. AND- BUT I HEARD
MENTION THAT THE STATE
CONNECTIVITY IS LACKING AND I
THINK THAT- THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT THAT'S OUR JOB TO TRY TO
HELP FACILITATE THAT AND I HOPE
THAT AS A RESULT OF THIS HEARING
THAT WERE. WE BECOME MORE AWARE
AND- WE CAN BECOME A PARTNER IN
TRYING TO- RIVERSIDE OF THIS
VERY TERRIBLE CIRCUMSTANCE.
THANK YOU. MISTER ISAAC D. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN JUST REALLY
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
CONVENING THIS REALLY IMPORTANT
HEARING ABOUT THIS REALLY
IMPORTANT TOPIC THE STATE HAS-
ATTENDED TO ADDRESS THIS IN A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT WAYS I'M
REALLY PROUD OF THE SAFE HARBOR
LAWS IN OTHER WAYS THAT WE'VE
LOOKED AT THIS. THROUGH THE
YEARS. IT IS- I THINK WE ALSO
NEED TO CONTINUE TO LOOK AT
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY AND
INCLUSION IN OTHER PARTS OF OUR-
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGES SO THAT WE
CAN FIGURE OUT HOW WE TIE ALL OF
THESE THINGS TO THE NEEDS OF OUR
COMMUNITY. BUT I'M GRATEFUL TO
THE- PRISONERS TODAY SO FAR
LOOKING FOR TO THE FULL
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU. ADULT
INTERNET THANK YOU MISTER MARCH
WE'RE GOING TO GO ON TO OUR NEXT
PANEL. AND THAT WOULD BE- WE
HAVE KIMBERLY FOSTER FROM THE
CRIME VICTIMS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE AND DR GRIFFITH A
SURVIVOR CONSULTANT LOYOLA LAW
SCHOOL- SUNITA JANE- ANTI
TRAFFICKING POLICY INITIATIVE.
AND SABRINA TO LOOK AFTER A
DIRECTOR OF FEDERAL POLICY LAW
LAWYER LAW SCHOOL- SO WE HAVE
TWENTY NOW WE HAVE WE HAVE A
HALF HOUR. SO WHERE ONCE YOU
BEGIN THEY MAY BEGIN FIRST. A.
B. COGNISANT YOU HAVE OTHER
PRESENTERS. I'M SORRY I SAID
KIMBERLY FOSTER WE HAD A CHANGES
TINA. AB ONE WHICH- TINA
RODRIGUEZ I GRABBED THE WRONG
SHE. YEAH. IN GETTING TO THE
PREVIOUS MY NAME'S ADRIANA
GRIFFITH FELKER. TINA REMOTELY.
YES CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. YOU MAY
BEGIN WARNING MORNING. MS
RODRIGUEZ YOU MAY BEGIN YOUR
TESTIMONY AT THE GIVE ABOUT FIVE
MINUTES OR SO. THANK YOU I'M.
I'M HAPPY TO BE HERE TO BE ABLE
TO HEAR DISCUSSION ABOUT- THAT
SOME OF THE HARDSHIPS AND
SURVIVORS ARE EXPERIENCING WHAT
I WILL SHARE WITH YOU THE L. IS
UNFORTUNATELY A STORY FROM A
SURVIVOR THAT IT'S CONTINUED TO
BE SCREENED OUT OF SERVICES AS
SHE IS IN. A SITUATION THAT IS
NOT VERY STATE BANK SHE'S DOING
EVERYTHING THAT SHE CAN'T TO TRY
AND ACCESS RESOURCES- KIMBERLY
WAS GOING TO SPEAK THIS MORNING
BUT ASKED ME TO SHARE HER STORY
FOR HER- SHE IS A SURVIVOR AND
OUR MEMBER NETWORK OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND FOLLOWING THAT
THE DEATH. OF HER. SORRY I HIT
SOMETHING HERE BUT- WE CAN HEAR
THAT YES THAT THIS SOMETHING
HAPPENED WITH THIS- DEVICE BUT
THAT FOLLOWING THE DEATH OF HER
MOTHER SHE SPIRALED INTO
DEPRESSION AND- STRUGGLED WITH A
LIFE PATH FROM THERE. ARE
RECRUITED INTO TRAFFICKING
BECAME A MATTER AT JUST LIKE IT
WAS DESCRIBED EARLIER BY BY THE
GENTLEMAN THAT SPOKE I THINK HIS
NAME WAS JOHN. MARSHALL THERE
DIED TRAPPED IN A SITUATION
WHERE WE'RE YOUR FAMILY WE
CONTROL EVERYTHING AND YOU'LL
SPEAK AND TALK TO WHOEVER WE
CHOOSE YOU SPEAK AND TALK. TO
AND CONTROLLING ENVIRONMENTS. SO
WE- GEOGRAPHICAL. TO REDUCE THE
SUPPORT SYSTEM ARE BASICALLY
ISOLATE FROM THE SUPPORT SYSTEM
WAS AN IMMEDIATE- AND IMMEDIATE
GROOMING I THAT TOOK PLACE TO
MAKE SURE THERE WAS NO WAY TO
ESCAPE- THE SITUATION THAT SHE'S
BEEN IN. AND OUT SHE APPLIED FOR
VICTIM COMPENSATION AND THAT IS
AND CONTINUES TO TRY AND GET
ASSISTANCE- THE RESPONSE TIME AT
THAT THE LACK OF TIME
SENSITIVITY TO URGENT CRISIS
MATTERS NEEDS TO BE IMPROVED
THEY CAN HELP BENEFIT TO
INCREASE THE STATE THING.
ESPECIALLY IN CRISIS SITUATIONS
LIKE HERS WHERE THERE IS AN
EFFORT TO AND THE ONE
OPPORTUNITY TO ESCAPE- A GET
AWAY IS. VITAL TO STAY ALIVE AND
WHEN THAT DOES HAPPEN IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO HAVE A
RESPONSE IN PLACE THEY REALLY
AMPLIFY SEEKING PROTECTION IN
THOSE MOMENTS IT IS DIFFICULT.
TO BE HOMELESS. AND NO DATE THAT
YOU'RE TARGETED OR FOR SPEAKING
IN FOR NEEDING AND THESE
TRAFFICKERS JUST LIKE IT WAS
DESCRIBED EARLIER WE'LL SEND
PEOPLE OUT TO LOOK FOR YOU- AT
SEARCH FOR YOU STOCK. THREATEN
OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS THAT'S ONE
OF THE REASONS WHY IT'S
DIFFICULT TO ESCAPE AND WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO WATCH IT HERE AND
JUST KNOW THAT- YOU KNOW WE ARE.
FEARFUL OURSELVES TO SEE- YOU
KNOW THAT THAT AMOUNT OF FEAR
AND THREATS THERE BUT IN
ADDITION TO THAT WE ALSO SEE
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO IMPROVE
OUR RESPONSE. AND WE REALLY WANT
TO BE MAKING SURE THAT WE
INCREASE AWARENESS AROUND THAT
AND THAT WE EXPEDITE OF REQUESTS
FOR SERVICES WHEN THEY WHEN THEY
DO PRESENT THEMSELVES. SO MAKING
SURE THAT- YOU KNOW THAT THAT WE
INCREASE RESPONSE TIME WHEN
SURVIVORS ARE ASKING FOR HELP
FOR THE FOR THE MENTAL HEALTH
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE HOUSING
MENTAL HEALTH AND- AND HEALTH
CARE. WITH SURVIVORS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING WE HAVE TO KEEP IN
MIND THAT RIGHT NOW WE'RE IN A
PANDEMIC AND SO IT'S NOT LIKE
BEFORE WHERE SURVIVORS. COULD
JUST WALK INTO AN EMERGENCY
HEALTH CLINIC AND BE SEEN- DATE
THERE'S USUALLY A SCREENING ARE
SOMETIMES THEY'RE TOLD TO CALL
THIS NUMBER WELL IF THEIR
PHONE'S BEEN TAKEN AWAY FROM
THEM AND THEY'RE NOT ALLOWED TO
SPEAK FREELY THAT'S IMPOSSIBLE.
SEOUL ARE REMOVING SOME OF THESE
BARRIERS IS VERY IN A- VERY
IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW IT'S A
DISCUSSION WE NEED TO HAVE AND
HELPING CAL BASICALLY UNDERSTAND
THAT- SURVIVORS THAT ARE
HOMELESS DON'T HAVE A MAILING
ADDRESS TO GET THESE DOCUMENTS.
AND WHEN YOU'RE IN A STATE OF
CRISIS AND YOU SEE THESE THINGS
YOU DON'T HAVE AN ADDRESS-
TRYING TO GET COMMUNICATED AS
BEST AS YOU CAN WITH NO DEVICE-
NO INTERNET ACCESS OVER TIME IS
VERY CHALLENGING. AND I
ENCOURAGE AT A CONTINUED EFFORT. TO INCREASE THESE MATTERS.
THANK YOU MISTER. NECK THE ATRIA
GRIFFITH. GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING. THANK YOU COMMITTEE FOR
PROVIDING SPACE THIS MORNING FOR
ME TO SHARE MY JOURNEY WITH YOU
ALL AND WHY BELIEVE IN NON
PERSONAL APPROACHES TO HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. MY NAME IS ADRIANA
GRIFFITH AND I LIVE IN STOCKTON
CALIFORNIA WHERE OVER THE LAST
FIVE YEARS I HAVE PROVIDED
DIRECT SERVICES TO VICTIMS OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT. DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
NOT ONLY HAVE I BEEN ABLE TO
WITNESS THE FAILURES OF OUR
CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM IN THE
LIVES OF THOSE I SERVE. BUT I'VE
ALSO EXPERIENCED THAT FIRST HAND
. I HAVE SHARED MY EXPERIENCE
SEVERAL TIMES AND THE SAME
QUESTION AS ALWAYS POSE. WHAT
MADE ME SO VULNERABLE THAT I
BECAME A VICTIM OF THIS THING
CALLED HUMAN TRAFFICKING. MOST
STORIES INVOLVE BEING ABUSED OR
NEGLECTED AS A CHILD. AND
NAVIGATING THROUGH THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM. MY JOURNEY DOES
NOT START THAT WAY. I GREW UP
WITH BOTH OF MY PARENTS IN THE
SAME HOUSEHOLD. IT WAS A HOME
FILLED WITH LOVE AND HAPPINESS
BUT IT WAS ALSO A HOME THAT
EXPERIENCE CONFLICT. PAIN AND
THE CHALLENGES THAT OFTEN
ACCOMPANY LIFE. I WASN'T ABUSED
IN MY HOME BUT I FREQUENTLY
WITNESSED MOMENTS THAT MADE ME
FEEL LESS TRUSTING AND LESS
SAFE. WHEN IT CAME TO THOSE
AROUND ME. THESE MOMENTS ARE
OFTEN CHARACTERIZED BY COMBAT OF
ARGUMENTS AND DUE TO THE SYSTEM
INVOLVEMENT OF SOME OF MY
SIBLINGS POLICE INTERACTIONS.
ONE MOMENT IN PARTICULAR THAT
STANDS OUT THAT NO CHILD SHOULD
EVER EXPERIENCE AS HAVING LAW
ENFORCEMENT ARMED WITH ASSAULT
WEAPONS BURST INTO MY HOME AND
POINT A GUN AT ME AS IF I WERE A
THREAT TO PUBLIC SAFETY. I WAS
ELEVEN YEARS OLD. NO ONE WAS
ARRESTED THAT DAY AND AFTER
HAVING TRAUMATIZED EVERYONE
PRESENT THEY LEFT CALLING IT A
PROBATION SEARCH. THERE WERE NO
SUPPORT OF SERVICES OFFERED TO
ME AFTER THAT. AND I WAS LEFT TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO COPE ON MY OWN
DESPITE THE SYSTEM KNOWING IT
HAD CONTACTED A MINOR AND SUCH A
HORRENDOUS WAY. AS ITRANSITION
FROM CHILDHOOD INTO MY TEENAGE
YEARS. I BEGAN TO EXPERIENCE
FEELINGS OF DEPRESSION AND
ANXIETY. WHEN I WAS SIXTEEN I
BEGAN TO SELF HARM AS A METHOD
OF COPING WITH THOSE FEELINGS.
GIVING ME A SENSE OF POWER AND
CONTROL BECAUSE I FELT LIKE I
HAD NONE. I HAD MOVED AWAY FROM
THE ONLY HOME I'D EVER KNOWN AND
OFTEN FELT LIKE I JUST DID NOT
BELONG. WHEN I WAS NINETEEN
AFTER GETTING MY FIRST BOYFRIEND
AND FALLING IN LOVE FOR THE
FIRST TIME. I BECAME PREGNANT.
THIS WAS ALSO THE SAME AGE I
EXPERIENCED MY FIRST BREAKUP AND
HEARTBREAK. I ULTIMATELY MADE
THE INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT CHOICE
TO HAVE AN ABORTION. AFTER WHICH
I FELT INCREDIBLE GUILT AND
SHAME. I WASN'T PREPARED THE
MENTAL ANIMAL AND OF THIS. IT
LEFT ME AND A STATE. BUT STILL
WAS NO FOLLOW UP CARE BY MY OR
HEALTH PROVIDERS. DESPITE HAVE A
HISTORY OF MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS IN MY FAMILY AS WELL AS
ADDICTION. ONCE AGAIN I WAS LEFT
TO COPE ON MY OWN AFTER COMING
IN CONTACT WITH THE SYSTEM THAT
IS SUPPOSED TO BE ABOUT HELPING
PEOPLE. NINETEEN WOULD ALSO BE
THE YEAR I'M INTRODUCED TO THE
WORLD OF SEXUAL EXPLOITATION. MY
EXPERIENCE HOWEVER WAS NOT THE
MAINSTREAM EXPERIENCE OFTEN
PORTRAYED IN OUR SOCIETY. AT
THIS TIME IN MY LIFE I WAS
EXTREMELY DEPRESSED AND LOOKING
FOR A WAY TO ESCAPE THE REALITY
OF ME. THE FAST PACED WORLD THAT
FACILITATED EXPLOITATION GAVE ME
THAT ESCAPE. IT GAVE ME A RASH
AND THE SENSE OF BELONGING. THIS
WORLD GAVE ME OF THE ABILITY TO
BE SOMEONE NOW. SOMEONE WHO
DIDN'T REMIND ME OF WHO I USED
TO BE AND COULD NEVER BE AGAIN.
FROM NINETEEN TO TWENTY TWO I
WAS TRAFFICKED AND SEXUALLY
EXPLOITED BY THREE DIFFERENT
PEOPLE. EACH PERSON WAS
DIFFERENT AND EACH RELATIONSHIP
WAS DIFFERENT. ONE WAS THE
BUSINESS TYPE ONE WAS THE ROMEO
TYPE AND THE OTHER WAS MY
BOYFRIEND. THE LAST EXPERIENCE I
HAD WAS WITH MY BOYFRIEND. IT
WAS WITH HIM THAT I HAD THE MOST
INTENSE RELATIONSHIP OF ALL. IT
WAS CHARACTERIZED BY VIOLENCE
GAS LIGHTING AND MANIPULATION
AND WAS EXTREMELY TOXIC FOR BOTH
OF US. AFTER A FEW MONTHS WE
BEGAN USING ALCOHOL AND DRUGS
MORE FREQUENTLY. WE INSERTED
OURSELVES BACK INTO THE CULTURE
OF PARTYING LIKE ROCK STARS AND
SOON AFTER I FOUND MYSELF
ENGAGING AND STREET AND ONLINE
PROSTITUTION. WHEN I WASN'T
HAVING SEX FOR MONEY I WAS
COMMITTING PETTY THEFT AT THE
MALL TO KEEP MONEY COMING IN.
THIS WAS EXPECTED AS PART OF THE
LIFESTYLE. IT DIDN'T STOP THERE
HOWEVER I WAS ALSO ENCOURAGED
AND SOMETIMES FORCED TO ENGAGE
IN PHYSICAL ASSAULTS TO OTHERS
FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS. THIS
UNFORTUNATELY ALSO MEANT
PARTICIPATING IN THE TRAFFICKING
AND EXPLOITATION OF OTHER PEOPLE
. I WAS TWENTY TWO YEARS OLD
WHEN I WAS ARRESTED AND CHARGED
WITH PIMPING PANDERING AND A
RANGE OF OTHER CHARGES FROM
ASSAULT TO KIDNAPPING. MY CO
DEFENDANT WAS ALSO THE PERSON
WHO TRAFFICKED AND EXPLOITED ME
. I SPENT TWO YEARS IN THE
COUNTY JAIL FIGHTING MY CASE
ANALYTICS ULTIMATELY SENTENCED
TO STATE PRISON FOR A TERM OF
FIVE YEARS. I SERVE THE REST OF
MY TIME UNDER THE CONTROL OF
CDCR. BEFORE COMING HOME IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN. THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE TIME I WAS INCARCERATED.
I WAS NEVER PROVIDED WITH ANY
SERVICES OR SPACE TO BE ABLE TO
SELF IDENTIFY AS A TRAFFICKING
VICTIM DESPITE HAVING COME IN
CONTACT WITH AN ENTIRE LEGAL
SYSTEM. INSTEAD I WAS ONCE AGAIN
LEFT TO SILENTLY COPE WITH WHAT
I HAD EXPERIENCED. THE SYSTEM
NEVER SAW ME AS A VICTIM. THIS
WAS EVIDENT AND ONE OF MY VERY
FIRST ENCOUNTERS WITH CDC ARE.
IN A COMMITTEE HEARING WHEN
BEING ASSIGNED TO A PRISON LABOR
ASSIGNMENT I WAS ASKED BY
LIEUTENANT WHY I HAD DONE WHAT
I'VE DONE. I SIMPLY TOLD HIM I
WAS TRYING TO SURVIVE. THAT IF I
DIDN'T DO WHAT WAS ASKED THE
CONSEQUENCES WOULD BE WORSE. AND
NOT SO MANY WORDS HE TOLD ME
THAT MY ACTIONS DIDN'T MAKE ANY
SENSE. BECAUSE LOOK WHERE IT GOT
ME. THEY LOOKED AT ME WITH
DISGUST AND SHAME. AND I LEFT
THAT ROOM FEELING LIKE THE WORST
PERSON ON THE PLANET. PRESENT
ITSELF IS SEXUALLY VIOLENT IN
NATURE DEHUMANIZING AND
INCONSIDERATE OF THE EXPERIENCES
TRAFFICKING AND SEXUAL ABUSE
SURVIVORS HAVE GONE THROUGH. I
HAVE BEEN FORCED BY THE SYSTEM
JUST STRIPPED COMPLETELY NAKED
WHILE SOMEONE I DID NOT KNOW
INSPECTED MY BODY AND THE MOST
DEHUMANIZING WAY POSSIBLE. THIS
WAS MY EXPERIENCE AS A SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND TRAFFICKING SURVIVOR
IN PRISON. FOR TOO LONG OUR
COUNTRY HAS OPERATED IN A WAY
THAT SAYS ACCOUNTABILITY EQUALS
PRISON. AT PRESENT AS A
DEHUMANIZING SYSTEM OF
PUNISHMENT AND REVENGE AND IT
DOES NOT FOSTER ACCOUNTABILITY
OR HEALING FOR ANYONE INVOLVED.
DESPITE BEING TRAFFICKED AND
SEXUALLY ABUSED AND EXPLOITED. I
HAVE SERVED MY TIME AND DONE
TREMENDOUS WORK TO BE
ACCOUNTABLE FROM MY PAST
ACTIONS. BUT THE STATE HAS NOT
BEEN ACCOUNTABLE TO ME. FOR THE
LAST SEVEN YEARS SINCE COMING
HOME I HAVE WORKED TO NOT ONLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT HAS HAPPENED TO
ME BUT TO ALSO MAKE SURE DOESN'T
CONTINUE TO HAPPEN TO OTHERS. SO
MUCH PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE WHEN
IT COMES TO THE ACCESS THAT
SURVIVORS HAVE. WHEN IT COMES TO
JUSTICE. BUT UNFORTUNATELY THIS
THE STATE HAS DECIDED TIME AND
TIME AGAIN. THAT ACCESS DOES NOT
APPLY TO ME OR OTHERS LIKE ME.
BECAUSE OF MY PREVIOUS
CONVICTION I AM AN ELIGIBLE FOR
RECORD EXPUNGEMENT OR VACATE A
RELEASE. SO WHILE THE STATE
CONTINUES TO RECOGNIZE. AND PASS
LEGISLATION THAT RECOGNIZES
HUMAN TRAFFICKING VICTIMS ARE AT
TIMES FORCED INTO OTHER ACTS OF
CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR IT CONTINUES
TO LEAVE THOSE LIKE ME OUT OF
THE EQUATION. WHAT THIS
COMMUNICATES TO ME IS THAT ONLY
SOME SURVIVORS ARE WORTH CARING
FOR AND OTHERS ARE NOT.
SURVIVORS DO NOT COME IN A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL MODEL. WE ARE ALL
DIFFERENT. WITH DIFFERENT NEEDS
AT DIFFERENT STAGES OF HEALING
AND WITH DIFFERENT EXPERIENCES.
THE APPROACH TO HELPING
SURVIVORS NEEDS TO ACKNOWLEDGE
AND HOLD SPACE FOR THOSE
DIFFERENCES. WHAT MADE ME
VULNERABLE TO TRAFFICKING WAS
BEING SYSTEM IMPACTED FROM A
YOUNG AGE HAVING AN ABORTION
WITHOUT PROPER MENTAL HEALTH
CARE IN THE AFTERMATH. IT WAS
BEING ANGRY AND FEELING A LACK
OF POWER AND CONTROL. IT WAS THE
MESSAGES I GOT FROM MUSIC TV
MOVIES. BUT MOST OF ALL THE
VULNERABILITY WAS NOT HAVING A
SPACE TO PROCESS ALL OF THAT IT
THE THINGS THAT HAVE HAPPENED TO
ME. WHEN WE HAVE A SYSTEM THAT
REFUSES TO ACKNOWLEDGE A
PERSON'S ENTIRE SELF AND THE
CHALLENGES THEY FACE. WE
CONTINUE TO SOLVE ONLY HALF THE
PROBLEM. AND WHETHER INTENDED OR
NOT. WE CONTINUE TO PERPETUATE
CYCLES OF HARM. OUR CURRENT
SYSTEM OPERATESBY LOOKING AT
WHAT A PERSON IS DYING AND
DECIDING WHAT PUNISHMENT THEY
DESERVE. BUT IT DOES NOT ASK THE
MOST IMPORTANT QUESTION WHICH IS
WHAT DOES THIS PERSON NEED IN
ORDER TO NO LONGER CAUSE HARM OR
EXPERIENCE HARM. THIS IS WHAT IT
MEANS TO APPROACH THIS ISSUE
FROM A NON PUNITIVE
INTERSECTIONAL LENS. THIS
APPROACH MATTERS TO ME BECAUSE I
STAND AT THE INTERSECTIONS OF
LIFE. I AM MADE UP OF MULTIPLE
EXPERIENCES AND IDENTITIES. I AM
A DAUGHTER A SISTER AND AUNTS. A
FORMERLY INCARCERATED SURVIVOR.
A SURVIVOR OF LIFE. AND A
SURVIVOR OF THE SYSTEM. IN EACH
ONE OF THOSE IDENTITIES IS
EQUALLY AS IMPORTANT AS THE NEXT
. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THIS
MORNING. IN THANK YOU AND GOOD
COULD YOU STERANKO YOU WILL HAVE
QUESTIONS AND- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR VERY PASSIONATE HAND
WRITTEN- TESTIMONIES SHE THAT IS
FROM YOU AND FROM YOUR HEART.
AND BEFORE WE GO ON- I KNOW MISS
MISS FOSTER COULDN'T COULDN'T BE
APPRECIATED DEATH IN THE FAMILY
I WOULD LIKE HER TO KNOW THAT
THIS THIS COMMITTEE. CENTER
CONDOLENCES BECAUSE IN MANY WAYS
BY IS NOT ACKNOWLEDGING PEOPLE'S
PAIN. WE'RE EXACERBATING THE
PROBLEM AND SO I KNOW THIS
COMMITTEE GENERALLY DOES FEEL
FOR THE FACT THAT SHE'S NOT HERE
LET US KNOW HOW DEEP THE PAIN
AND TRAUMA. OF THAT INDIVIDUAL
WHO INVOLVED IN HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IS. NOT WE'LL HEAR
FROM- SOON NEED. J. FOR OKAY
HELLO. OUR SABRINA I GOT TO.
WHO'S NEXT. HELLO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
SABRINA. ONE OF OUR THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND FOR
PROVIDING AT THE BASIC OUT THE
WANTED ACTION AND TRAFFICKING
AND PUBLIC EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA
MY NAME IS SABRINA TO OBJECT I
AM A FEDERAL POLICY DIRECTOR AT
THE NEED TO CHANGE HI
TRAFFICKING ALICIA AT LOYALSOCK
ONE. PREVIOUSLY I WORKED AT THE
LEGAL AID SOCIETY IN NEW YORK
CITY AND REPRESENTED CLAIMED OR
INCARCERATED NONCITIZEN
SURVIVORS OF TRAFFICKING FELONY
CHARGES IN YOUR IMMIGRATION
CRIMINAL PROCEEDINGS. HOW HUMAN
TRAFFICKING SURVIVORS ARE
RUNNING WITH THE BALL IN
CRIMINAL AND CIVIL ENFORCEMENT.
BACKING Y. ARRESTING SURVIVORS
DOES NOT MAKE COMMUNITIES PARK
AND THIRD EIGHT POINT SEVEN
INTEREST ACTUAL NON CARPOOL
TRUSTEES TRAFFICKING IN PUBLIC
WHICH. HOW ARE YOU MENTOR
SURVIVORS AND THE BALL WE THE
PORTION. JEFF INDULGING A SECOND
CLOSE YOUR EYES AND THINK A
HUMAN SURVIVOR. WHO GOING IT'S
FOR IN MIND. WHAT IS RATE ON JAN
IDENTITY AND WHAT WOULD OR. DID
CHANGE HER HAVE A CRIMINAL OR
SOMETHING IS NOT
CONSTITUTIONALLY. ATTY BE THEY
ARE IN TURN GAVE OF WHO THE
TRACK DEVICE ISN'T. BECAUSE THE
CORE TO THE LACK OF I. AFTER
BEFORE CLEARING OUT YOUR
EXPERIENCE IN CRIMINAL AND CIVIL
AND FOR THAT. THE OVER ARCHING
ISSUE AND ALLOW OF ITEM. THANK
PEOPLE WORK WITHIN FIFTH. HI IN
NOT AT THE MAIN SHOW NARRATIVE
TRAFFICKING AT TWO O'CLOCK IN
OUR CHARGE. LOOMING IN COULD GO
UP WITH MY FORCED. PRIOR
CRIMINAL. AND MARK. SURVIVORS
ENSURE THE FORTY SYSTEM THE
POINT OF A RED AND PLETHORA
STARK THAT. MANY ARE FOR TO
COMMIT AS A NEW TO ALL OF THE
FOREST BOB AND COERCION OF THEIR
TRY RECORD. IT'S ONE NOW THAT
BEFORE THAT WORKS ABOUT ISN'T
NECESSARILY HOLDEN AND GRANTED
THEM AT AND TO NOT IT IF THE
MATCH SUBTLE MANIPULATED OF
COERCION. HE'S CRYING WHAT WHAT
WE CAN MAKE THANK AT THOSE TRACK
. I CONNECTING CHARGE ARE PASSED
AND POSSESSION WHICH MAKE THE A
LITTLE MORE LIKELY TO GREEN FOR.
HOWEVER IN MY BACK IF THE
CHARGES ARE OFTEN MORE. WE FROM
THE TO. THE TICKET AGAIN THE OR
- AND TRAFFICKING MINORS. SOME
ALL FORGET IT BEING THAT BIG
DEBTS CAN ALSO BE. THE SITUATION
IS EVEN MORE FOR NON TO SURVEY
AND THEIR VOTE AND FORCE THAT
THE WAY THEY CAN BE LAW ARRESTED
DETAINED BUT THE FOURTH
PROTECTION OF THE CONSTITUTION.
NON DIVERS AND I PROVIDE. A GARY
AN IMMIGRATION ATTORNEY THEIR
PROCEEDINGS. YES BANK CREATE AND
EMPOWER FOR SERVICE TO SELF
IDENTIFY WITH INDECENT. SITE
WITHIN CENTER. FIFTY REQUIRED TO
PER ARCHED. AND MOVE BEYOND COMP
CYCLE AND CHAU. IN ORDER TO AND
THE NEW. OF SECOND. DIFFERENT
REQUIRES TO STATE THAT SOMEONE
THE THEY LOVE LIKE PARENT MIGHT
BE THEIR EXPO. DENY KNOW WHAT'S
AT ARMS WILL NOT SHOT THAT COULD
THEM IN HERE BUT IN DETAILS OF
LIFE. AGAIN IMPOSSIBLE REQUIRE
AND ARE CAST. THE BLACK OF NIGHT
AND- BEFORE DURING AND AFTER
INNER. HAS DIRE. WE ARE. TO
GATHER AT DATA ON BEEN. HOW AND
WHY. AND WITHOUT IDENTIFICATION
SURVIVORS ARE ON A TO. ACCESS IF
STATE AND FEDERAL. THEY'RE
LAWFULLY AND. TO BUT IT IS NOT
AN THE CENTRAL OF TODAY CARE.
WHY DO THIS MATTER IF PEOPLE
COMMITTING ARE CAPPED FROM
COMMUNITY LARGE R. O. ALL SEE.
THE ANSWER IS NOW. A PLETHORA
HAVE. THAT AS LONG AS THE BUYER
THE CRIMINAL HISTORY HAVE YOU
PRIMARY ACROSS. AND ARE JUST WAY
. FOR MEDINA STATE FEDERAL
TRAFFICKING PACIFIC SERVICE
BEARING HIGHER TO. IT HI LIKELY
THAT WE WILL BE WE IN MY OR AT
LEAST RENDERED BOND. TO
TRAFFICKING AGAIN. IN MY CASE
LOAD OF THE MINIMUM OF A HUNDRED
TAKE PER YEAR ALMOST EVERY. UP I
KNOW HOW DO. MULTIPLE TIMES IN
THEIR LIFE. DESPITE INTO. WITH
DIFFERENT INPUTS EXTENT AGAIN
HAD MULTIPLE AND LIFE. THE ALL
WAY TO KEEP THEM BONTA MEMBERS
OF OUR TEAM STATE IS REVIVED BY
WOULD BE PULLED EIGHT ON TWO OR
TO COME FORWARD. AND THE ONLY TO
CALM TRAP INTRODUCTION THINK
LARA. ACTOR INTO AND PROBY
ALLOCATE OF THE THAT WHICH WILL
ONLY HAPPEN SHIPPED FOCUS TO
ENTER. PREVENTION TO IDENTIFY
THEIR ARE KERN IN A THAT THE
FEEL I P. TO COME. ACTIVE ON
IMMIGRATION STATUS OR GENDER
IDENTITY OVERLAP AND EXPERIENCES
OF MARGINALIZED GROUPS. IF YOU
NEED TO CHANGE ANTI TRAFFICKING
INITIATIVES IMPLORED
STAKEHOLDERS TO SHIFT THEIR
FOCUS ON PUBLIC COMMENT
FORTUNATE TO PUBLIC HEALTH AND
COMMUNITY BASED APPROACH TO
ADOPT AN INTERSECTIONAL RAN TO
THE SURVIVOR EXPERIENCE. AND WHO
LOOK AT THE RED CAUSE OF WHAT
MAKES SOMEONE VULNERABLE TO
TRAFFICKING. FOR EXAMPLE WHEN WE
LOOK AT THE INTERSECTION ALITY
OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND HOW THAT
MAKE THEM UNVIABLE TO
TRAFFICKING CLIMATE DISASTERS
CARS LARGELY AND PEOPLE AND RUN
YOUR ENTIRE NEIGHBORHOOD COMPLEX
. AS WE'VE SEEN WITH HURRICANE
KATRINA AND HURRICANE. THANK
MONIQUE. YOUNG PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITY BONE TO ACTUALLY.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF INTEREST AT
ALITY IN GERMAN TRACK IF THE
ROLE OF BIG AND MEDIA IN
ALLOWING THE OF MAKING ABOUT
TRACK. SUCH AS WITH THE
TRAVELING AQUINO IT ONLY TO BE
DONE AFTER THAT FALL OUTSIDE IT
MEANS CARE HI. EIGHTY AGAIN FOR
TO THE TIME TO UNDER YOUR OF
TRAP AND SPEAKING ESPECIALLY
FROM. ACTED AND DELTA AND OR
CONCERNS. THANK YOU- WE'RE NOW.
BRING IT TO THE FOR QUESTIONS
ARE FORCED REYES STATE- BUT
FIRST THE WHEN I FROM THE
VICTIMS. ON MY RECENT. A WANT TO
PURSUE HER ABOUT THE THESE TO
USED TO LIKE- HUMANS WHO
TRAFFICKING SLAVERY AND I
RECENTLY JUST SAW RESULT THE
MOVIE ABOUT TWELVE YEARS JUST.
AND IT WAS A SOMEONE THAT WAS.
THAT ALL OF A SUDDEN. GOT ALL
THAT TAKEN AWAY FROM THEM HE WAS
A SLAVE. ALL OF THE METHODOLOGY
. ALL OF THE TECHNIQUES ALL OF
THE PROCEDURES SEEM VERY
SIMILAR. TO HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
TAKING YOU AWAY FROM YOUR
FAMILY- BECOMING A PROPERTY YOUR
PROPERTY OF A GROUP OF A PERSON
OR GROUP OF PEOPLE. AND FOR
ANOTHER HUMAN BEING TO TREAT
ANOTHER HUMAN BEING THAT WAY
PROBABLY THE MOST HEINOUS THING
THAT COULD HAPPEN IS ONE REASON
I WANT TO HAVE. THIS HEARING TO
LET PEOPLE KNOW THAT THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE PARTICIPATING IN THIS
ARE PROBABLY THE COOLEST MOST
INHUMANE INDIVIDUALS MAY BE EVEN
ON THE PLANET. AND- THAT'S WHY
WE'VE GOT TO GET TO THE ROOT OF
IT BECAUSE YOU BECOME
TRAUMATIZED AFTER YOU'VE ALREADY
BEEN TRAUMATIZED IN THE PLAY ON
THAT. TO KEEP CONTROL AS THEY
DID WITH US SLAVES IN THE SOUTH
TO KEEP HIM FROM RUNNING AWAY.
TO KEEP THEM FROM REVOLTING IF
YOU DID SOMETHING YOU COULD BE
SERIOUSLY INJURED. ARE YOU COULD
BE KILLED AND SELL OUT THAT KEPT
THAT WHOLE SYSTEM TOGETHER. AND
SO- WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT IN OUR
HEARD FROM SEVERAL OF THE PALACE
. LET THERE DIDN'T SEEM TO BE
ANY OFF RAMPS ARE PLACES YOU CAN
GO IMMEDIATELY BECAUSE IN MY
TIME IS REALLY IMPORTANT. THAT
ALMOST LIKE THE UNDERGROUND
RAILROAD DO WE NEED TO BUILD A
UNDERGROUND RAILROAD FOR HUMAN
TRAFFICKING WE CAN GET. THESE
INDIVIDUALS INVOLVED IN THIS OUT
OF IT QUICKLY WE CAN GET HIM TO
A SAFE PLACE AND WE KEEP THEM
AWAY FROM THE PERPETRATORS IS
THAT SOMETHING WE NEED TO INVEST
MORE MONEY IN. THIS SOMETHING
THAT WE REALLYNEED TO LOOK AT
AND MAYBE EVEN I'M USING THE
TERM UNDERGROUND RAILROAD
BECAUSE- THAT WAS THE MOST
EFFECTIVE THING AT THE TIME IT'S
JUST SOMETHING WE NEED AT THE
STATE. TO CORRECT THAT KIND OF
RAILROAD TO GET PEOPLE OUT OF
THAT THAT SYSTEM DOES THAT MAKE
ANY. ANY SENSOR HELP. I WAS
NABBED PANEL ANSWERED IN THE
SOCIETY IN MISTER BRYANT. ANYONE
FROM THE PANEL I CAN ANSWER SOME
OF THE PATTERN SHARE SOME OF MY
THOUGHTS ON THAT SO- SO I HEAR
USE USING THE WORDS SLAVERY IN
TERMS OF WHAT HAPPENED THE THREE
FOUR HUNDRED YEARS AGO- BUT I
ALSO WANT TO DRAW A COMPARISON
TO. OUR OUR PRISON SYSTEM IN THE
PRISON INDUSTRIAL COMPLEX AND
THAT AND HOW THAT IS ALSO ROOTED
IN SLAVERY- AND HOW ME AS A
SURVIVOR OF EXPLOITATION. BECAME
THE PROPERTY OF THE STATE. AND
SO I DEFINITELY UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOWEVER. I DON'T THINK THAT IT'S
NECESSARILY THE SAME CONTEXT AND
HERE'S WHY I SAY THAT- MY
PARTICULAR EXPERIENCE AGAIN WITH
MY LAST EXPERIENCE WAS WITH MY
BOYFRIEND THIS WAS SOMEBODY THAT
I CARED ABOUT. SOMEBODY THAT
DESPITE EVERYTHING THAT WE HAVE
BEEN THROUGH EVERYTHING THAT
HE'S DONE EVERYTHING THAT I'VE
DONE I STILL CARE ABOUT THIS
PERSON AS A AS A HUMAN BEING-
AND SO IT'S NOT AS SIMPLE AS
GETTING SOMEBODY AWAY FROM THE
PERSON THE TIMING THEM. BECAUSE
EVEN THOUGH I WAS SEPARATED FROM
HIM WHILE INCARCERATED STILL
VERY MUCH ATTACHED TO HIM- STILL
VERY MUCH ATTACHED TO THE
LIFESTYLE OF TRAFFICKING AND-
SOME OF THE- BENEFITS OF THE
REWARDS THAT I GOT OUT OF THAT
WHICH IS A SENSE OF PRIDE A
SENSE OF POWER AND CONTROL
EXCEPT FOR US- AND SO I THINK
THAT THAT THE ANSWER IS NOT.
JUST GETTING SOMEBODY AWARE
REMOVED REMOVING THEM FROM AN
ENVIRONMENT BUT IT'S AGAIN
REALLY LOOKING AT THE ROOT
CAUSES OF THE BEHAVIOR ON NOT
ONLY THE VICTIM OF THE SURVIVORS
SIDE BUT ALSO ON THE EXPLOITER
SIDE AS WELL- BECAUSE THERE ARE
PEOPLE IN A LOT OF THE TIMES. WE
COME FROM THE SAME COMMUNITIES
WE COME FROM THE SAME
NEIGHBORHOODS AND SO THERE'S NOT
A HUGE POWER IMBALANCE THERE IS
A GAME WHERE WE BOTH AND POVERTY
WITH BOTH LACK OF EDUCATION OR
WHATEVER THAT MIGHT BE- AND SO
AGAIN I JUST THINK THAT THE
ANSWER IS IT GETTING TO THE
ROOT. OF WHY FOLKS. WHAT ARE
PEOPLE GETTING OUT OF THE
BEHAVIORS THAT THEY'RE DEALING
BECAUSE WE'RE ALL GETTING
SOMETHING OUT OF WHAT WE ENGAGE
AND ESPECIALLY ON THE- ON THE
EXPLOITERS SIDE BECAUSE I ALSO
ENGAGED IN EXPLOITATION ON THAT
SIDE OF IT- TO WHERE I CONVINCE
PEOPLE TO. EXPLOIT THEMSELVES OR
TO- STYLE THEMSELVES AS WELL-
BUT IT WAS AGAIN I WAS LACKING A
WHOLE LOT OF THINGS I WAS
LACKING COPING SKILLS I WAS
LACKING PEOPLE SKILLS. I WAS
LACKING RELATIONAL SKILLS THERE
IS A LOT OF THINGS THAT I WAS
LACKING ON A BASIC HUMAN LEVEL.
TO BE ABLE TO RELATE TO ANOTHER
HUMAN BEING. AND THE WAY THAT
OUR SOCIETY OPERATES AND SORT
OF. LIKE RAISES ALL TO BE IS WE
LEARN TO SEE EACH OTHER AS
PRODUCTS AND NOT PEOPLE. AND IN
THAT IS THE ISSUE- A LOT OF THIS
STUFF IS ROOTED IN CAPITALISM
AND- THIS PATRIARCHAL IDEAS OF
POWER AND CONTROL AND WHO. GETS
TO BE THE BOSS AND WHO DOESN'T-
AND SO I THINK WE NEED TO ATTACK
THOSE SPECIFIC SYSTEMS- AND
REALLY WORK TO DISMANTLE THOSE
SYSTEMIC HARMS. SO THAT WE DON'T
CONTINUE TO PERPETUATE CYCLES
BECAUSE AGAIN WE CAN CONTINUE TO
INCARCERATE PEOPLE THAT'S NOT
GOING TO STOP THE PROBLEM. WHAT
IT'S A HUMAN PROBLEM AT THAT
PUBLIC HEALTH PROBLEM AND IT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED AT THAT
WAY. NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED BY
PROVIDING CARE TO. YOUNG BOYS
AND YOUNG MEN WHO WE IDENTIFY AS
HAVING SOME BEHAVIOR ISSUES AND
WE NEED TO GET TO THE ROOT OF
THAT. RECOGNIZING YOUNG MEN AND
WOMEN AND GIRLS AND THE PEOPLE
OF ALL GENDERS WHO STRUGGLE WITH
ISSUES OF SUBSTANCE ABUSE OR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ISSUES. RIGHT
BECAUSE THAT CAN ALSO TURN INTO
AN EXPLOITIVE RELATIONSHIP.
DEPENDING ON WHAT THE NEED IS-
AND SO I THINK THOSE ARE SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT WE NEED TO THINK
ABOUT WHEN IT COMES TO
ADDRESSING AND WHERE WE'RE
PUTTING OUR FUNDING AND THINGS
LIKE THAT WHEN IT COMES TO
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE. THANK YOU. FOR SANTIAGO. FOR THE RECORD
NUMBER OF COMMERCE. ALLOWED
NUMBER. DAYS TWO. THREE FOUR
FOUR MEMBERS OF TO SPEAK. A CUT
IN FRONT OF THE PANEL GROUP
WE'RE WE'RE FINISH WITH ALL THE
TO. ON IN THIS SAID UPON- EACH
SIDE SMALL THE- GO AHEAD AND HAS
QUESTIONS AND I'LL BE COULD THAT
THE SISTER IS BROKEN I DON'T I
AGREE A 100% WITH WHAT YOU IN
TURN OF HAVING MORE. OF THE FOR
LACK OF BETTER WORD I'LL CALL IT
SUPPORTS. I DON'T HAVE A BETTER
THAN THAT NOT ALL YOU THE WAY-
IF. OR HELP THEM GET AWAY
BECAUSE IT'S WHAT YOU IT BUT
WE'VE USED AND IN THE DOESN'T TO
BE. EVEN A LOT TO GET YOUR- TO.
WHAT LOOK AT TWENTY I THINK ANY
TO THAT WE DEFINITELY HAVEN'T
HAVE OPPOSED NOT NOT SUPPORT BUT
- AND IN THE WAY THAT WE SHOULD
BECAUSE I. WE EITHER. SO IT OR
SUPPORT IT WOULD DOLLARS AND
THEY HAVE THE SUPPORT OF A
DOLLARS OF THEM AND IN ORDER FOR
THEM TO HAVE ANY REAL IMPACT
RIGHT AT THE BOTTOM LINE. THE
SECOND THING IS WE'VE GOT TO
FIGURE OUT THE PREVENT THE
PIECES AND I'M GLAD THAT YOU
TOUCHED ON THAT BECAUSE THAT. IT
WAS RUNNING INSIDE OF ME FIGURE
OUT WHAT WHAT ARE THE RIGHT
BECAUSE I THINK. YOU DID A
CONVERSATION- THAT HAVE NOT EVER
HEARD BEFORE- IT. ON THE HUMAN
ASPECT OF NEED WHICH I THINK IS
VERY POWERFUL- A. N. N. A. SIX.
THAT QUESTION ABOUT PREVENTION.
YEAH THE OTHER PIECE OF IT TO
THE BECOMES VERY DIFFICULT I AM
INTERESTED TO GET YOUR OPINION-
BUT IT YOU KNOW AND I BATTLED
WITH THE FROM THE LEGISLATURE AS
WELL AND THE CURRENT COMMITTEE
CHAIR IN THE PREVIOUS COMMITTEE
CHAIRED HELPED US WITH US IN
THIS COMMITTEES GRAPPLED ON IT.
SO WE'VE TALKED ABOUT SUPPORT
SERVICES FOR LACK OF BETTER WORD
WE TALK ABOUT PREVENTION. BUT
ULTIMATELY YOU BUMP UP AGAINST
THE QUESTION A PROSECUTION.
BECAUSE ITBECAUSE THESE ARE ALL
THINGS THAT WE SHOULD DO THAT W
HAVE TO DO. BUT IN ORDER TO STOP
THIS ORGANIZED- CRIME THIS
ORGANIZED EFFORT. WE'VE WE DO
BUMP AGAINST WHAT THIS COMMITTEE
HISTORICALLY HAS FOUGHT IN
CRIMINALISATION ACTS. BECAUSE WE
HAVE DONE WELL IN THE
LEGISLATURE NOT NOT BUT WELL THE
LEGISLATURE D. DECRIMINALIZE.
CERTAIN ACCESS TO TRY TO FIX A
BROKEN- CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
. BUT IF WE DON'T- IF WE DON'T
STOP WITH A BY STOP I USE THE
BIG WERE PROSECUTION AND CLIMB
UP THE LADDER STOP THE SO THAT'S
KIND I MEAN WE'RE REALLY GOING
TO BE DEALING WITH. SUPPORT
SERVICES WHICH WHICH WHICH I'M A
100% FOR WHICH PREVENTIVE
SERVICES BUT WILL NEVER WE
TACKLE THE BIG PROBLEM. YOU KNOW
WONDER WHAT YOUR PERSPECTIVE IS
ON THAT BECAUSE IT'S ONE THING.
TO DECRIMINALIZE ACCESS SHOULD
NEVER INTERNALIZED TO BEGIN WITH
IT AND I'M WITH YOU ON THAT AB
BUT THEN HOW DO WE DEAL WITH
THIS LAST PIECE. BECAUSE
ULTIMATELY WHAT WE'RE SEEING. IS
NOT GOING TO STOP UNLESS WE
TAKE. ALL THE ACTIONS SAID HERE
AND MANY MORE THIS ONE TO KIND
OF GET YOUR IN. YOUR IMPROVE THE
COMMISSION BUT FOR THAT MATTER I
MEAN IT'S WORTH THE CONVERSATION
. YEAH I THINK YOU BRING UP A
REALLY GOOD POINT- AND I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT I'M
UNDERSTANDING YOUR QUESTION IS.
ARE YOU ASKING SPECIFICALLY ON
LIKE MY THOUGHTS ON HOW
PROSECUTION SHOULD WHAT
PROSECUTION SHOULD LOOK LIKE.
AND A NON CARCERAL SORT OF
APPROACH OR- FOR THOSE NOT FOR
THOSE WHO'VE EXPERIENCED HUMAN
TRAFFICKING YEAH. BUT JUST ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF ON THE OTHER
SIDE AND I'M OUT THERE ENGAGING
IN THE EXPLOITATION RECKON I'M
NOT YOU KNOW. EVEN FOCUS ON THE
QUOTE UNQUOTE BOTTOM LEVEL OF
TOTAL BUT THAT THERE IS A
NETWORK THAT THAT NEEDS TO STOP
OR WE'LL NEVER. MAKE A DRINK
AND- OR MET NEVER- REALLY FIGHT
THIS BACK HOLY. YEAH SO I THINK
THAT. YOU KNOW WHEN IT COMES TO.
PROSECUTION OR- IN ALL DEALINGS
THE FOLKS THAT ARE CAUSING THE
HARM RIGHT- AND I THINK I'M JUST
GONNA GO BACK TO WHAT I'M SAYING
ABOUT. SORT OF PREVENTION AND
MAYBE THIS IS MORE OF AN
INTERVENTION- BUT THERE SHOULD
BE. PROGRAMS I'M NOT SAYING THE
HOLD FOLKS ACCOUNTABLE- BUT WHAT
I'VE LEARNED THROUGHOUT MY
JOURNEY AND THE WORK THAT I DO-
IS THE ACCOUNTABILITY IS A
PROCESS AND IT'S NOT SO MUCH OF.
LIKE YOU DID SOMETHING BAD
HERE'S YOUR PUNISHMENT NOT HOLD
YOU ACCOUNTABLE RIGHT- YOU HAVE
TO GET TO A PLACE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY. WHERE IS YOU
HAVE TO GET TO A PLACE OF
UNDERSTANDING THE HARM THAT YOU
CAUSE. THE HARM THAT THE OTHER
PERSON EXPERIENCED IN THE IMPACT
THAT THAT HAD NOT JUST ON THEM.
BUT ON THE WHOLE COMMUNITY AS
WELL AS THAT PERSON'S FAMILY AS
WELL AND SO I THINK THAT IT'S
STARTING WITH. AGAIN HOLDING
FOLKS ACCOUNTABLE AND SAYING HEY
THIS IS THE HARM THAT YOU
BECAUSE BUT NOW WE'RE GOING TO
WORK ON YOU. NOW WE'RE GONNA
WORK ON HELPING YOU GET TO A
PLACE OF UNDERSTANDING AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND MAYBE THAT
LOOKS LIKE INSTITUTING MORE
PROGRAMS WITH IN. PRISON UNTIL
WE GET TO. THE PLACE WHERE WE NO
LONGER HAVE THE NEED FOR PRISONS
BUT IN THE MEANTIME I THINK THAT
HAVING MORE PROGRAMS IN PLACE
WHERE FOLKS ARE ABLE TO SORT OF
PROCESS TO THESE HARMFUL.
IDEOLOGIES AND- IDEOLOGIES THEIR
MENTALITIES THAT THEY'VE HAD A
GROWN ACCUSTOMED TO OUR GROWN UP
WITH AS NORMAL- I THINK THAT
THAT'S REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT
AND I THINK THAT THAT IS A
PIECE. THAT THE OTHER SIDE HAS
BEEN LACKING- WE LOCK HOLDS UP
AND WE DON'T ADDRESS ANY OF THAT
AND AGAIN I'LL USE MY OWN MY OWN
STORY AS AN EXAMPLE. WHEN I WAS
INCARCERATED. NO ONE EVER ASKED
ME ABOUT THE PERSON WHO ARE
HARMED NO ONE EVER ASKED ME
ABOUT THE IMPACT THAT THAT MIGHT
HAVE HAD ON THEM. ON MYSELF
AGAIN THINGS LIKE THAT WERE NOT
ADDRESSED AND SO- THERE'S A LOT
OF FOLKS THAT STAYED ON THE
INSIDE HAVING NEVER. LEARNED ARE
GETTING THE OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN
THESE CONCEPTS UNTIL
UNDERSTANDING GET TO A PLACE OF
UNDERSTANDING WHY THEY DID WHAT
THEY DID- AND I THINK THAT'S A
PIECE THAT THAT NEEDS TO BE
INCORPORATED. AND PROSECUTION
UNTIL WE GET TO A PLACE IN
SOCIETY WHERE WE NO LONGER HAVE
ANY FOR PRESENCE BUT IF YOU.
DON'T BUY- I LIKE TO GET TO THE
OTHER I GOT A LITTLE AMBITIOUS
BECAUSE WE FINISHED ABOUT. EIGHT
MINUTES TO HAVE THE TIMES ARE
START ASKING QUESTIONS OR- I SEE
WE HAVE. ALL LOT SO I KNOW
MISTER BRIAN HAS A QUESTION FOR
THE COURT AND- RESPONSE COULD
YOU HOLD ON ME GET TO. LAKE TO
THEM WHICH IS DIVE RIGHT INTO
JUST WHICH QUESTION. A GREAT.
BURKE IT IS GOING TO GO TO NEXT
TO GET THE MOTHER WAY HERE THEM
AND THEY WE CAN. GO INTO
QUESTIONING I JUST GOT A LITTLE
TOO AND- ON. UNDER MY CELL. SO
ON METAL MAC. ALLEN THANK PANEL
IF YOU STICK A TO THE SONGS ARE
. ARE OF QUESTIONS FOR. FROM
FROM THE PANEL HERE- SERVING
HERE MADISON MAC NATALIE MAY
CHIEF DEPUTY IS THAT OFFICER.
CALIFORNIA VICTOR COME. BOARD
GOOD MORNING AND YOU CHAU SOME
MEMBERS. AT IT'S INTERESTING TO
HEAR THESE TESTING AND YOU KNOW
HER ADDRESS STRAIGHT LAST
STORIES ARE THESE ARE THINGS
COME TO THE ARE GONNA QUITE THAT
. AT MELMASON. MISSION IS TO CAN
IN THE CURRENT RESTORED PROCESS
. AND SO SINCE THE- OF HUMAN AS
A COMPENSABLE NO TWENTY FOURTEEN
RESPECTS APPLICATIONS AND BEING
ABLE TO COMPENSATE THESE FOLKS
ARE BY WITH MEDICAL MENTAL
HEALTH RELOCATION ALL THE
BENEFITS THAT ARE HELPFUL TO
VICTIMS HI CALIFORNIA AND. IT'S
BEEN A VERY. SIX SESIL AND- THE
EX THAT YOU CAN HAVE SUCCESS IN
THE OF TRAGEDY RIGHT. I NEED
SOME OF WHAT WE BIG. AND I'M
GONNA SHOW. IT THEY SAID THAT. I
CAN. BUT I'LL JUST TALKS. THIS
GLOBAL DISH THIS WITH PROJECT
SLIDE. SINCE THE DISTRICT CAN
READ THE. HELLO WE A LOT OF
ANSWERED ABOUT 89% WITHIN THE
START. AND THAT'S QUITE HIGH BUT
TO POINT ARE BEING MADE HERE. WE
ARE A- ARE WE- REIMBURSEMENT
PROGRAM WE ARE SOMEWHAT WHO
COMES IN AFTER FACT AND A LOT OF
WHAT WE'RE HEARING TODAY IS VERY
DIFFERENT TO THAT AT YOUR JOB
FOR WE HAVE TO HAVE CERTAIN TO
MATT WE HAVE TO HAVE SOME VALLEY
. THAT SOME IS A VICTIM AND I
KNOW THAT THAT IS STRONG IN THIS
AND WELL THE REASON THAT HAVE
BEEN YOU KNOW I CAN TO CAN BE IN
THE CONNECTION ON THE TOP TO THE
TO THE PEOPLE WHO ARE VICTIMS
THEM. BUT FOR US. THERE ARE SOME
THAT HAVE BE MET. WE HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO DO. SOMEONE'S BEEN A
HUMAN TRAFFIC. OR SEX. TRADE
WORK VICTIM. AND SOME OF THE
CHANNELS THAT HAVE. IN TIME. AND
GETTING THE DOCUMENT JUST. THAT
SOME OF THEM LOOKS LIKE- IT'S-
NOT BEING ABLE TO GET PEOPLE ARE
TRYING OR VICTIM AS- TO COME.
WHEN THEY REACH ALREADY SO THAT
WE GET AIM FOR AND GET THE
NUMBER OF THEIR ENTIRE TO. OUR
AND AGAIN THAT'S TIME COMPONENTS
THAT FOLKS ABOUT. IT'S HARD TO
FOLLOW UP AND TO DO THAT.
ANOTHER TO COME THAT IS HAS BEEN
A CHALLENGE FOR SOME OF OUR COST
HAS BEEN GETTING DECLARATIONS
THAT SHOW- THAT THEY WERE IN
HUMAN TRAFFICKED. EARLY ON IN
THE M. OF THE PRO SOME THE CHILD
. WERE TIED TO. NOT BEING ABLE
TO DELINEATE BETWEEN. HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AS THE CRIMES VERSUS
A MOLESTATION. SO WE GET RECORDS
THAT SHOW- SOMEONE'S APPLYING
HUMAN TRAFFICKING OR SEX VICTIM
. BUT WE GET A POLICE REPORT OF
SOME SORT FOR EXAMPLE. THAT
INDICATES THAT THIS IS A PERSON
WHO'S HAD A BIG. MOLESTATION
WELL. IF THE TWO CRIMES ALMOST
HEINOUS AND BOTH COMPENSABLE
WORK PROGRAMS THEY'RE
COMPENSATED DIFFERENTLY BECAUSE
HUMAN TRAFFICKING HAS THE
DEPRIVATION OF LIBERTY COMPOUND
WHERE YOU CAN BE COMPENSATED FOR
- JUST. AN ABILITY OR CHECK TO
TEN THOUSAND YEAR WITH. TWO
YEARS ONCE GETS A TWENTY DOLLARS
SO THERE ARE SOME NUANCES HIGH
THINK THOSE NUANCES HAVE BEEN
IRONED OUT OVER TIME LARGELY
INVOLVED AND WE HAVE. FAR LESS
CHALLENGES WITHOUT THEM USED TO-
OVER THE COURSE OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION SINCE THE CLINTON
SESSION COMPONENT BECAME SEER
THAT WE'VE PAID OUT ABOUT TWO
POINT TWO MILLION. BUT THE STAFF
SEARCHES I. IS WE'VE ONLY HAD
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
APPLICATIONS. WHICH IS A LARGE
NUMBER BUT- LARGELY UNDERSTATES
THE POPULATION HAS BEEN
VICTIMIZED SO- WELL WE DO
SURROUND REGION WE'VE GOT
WEBSITE COMPONENTS YOU KNOW
UPDATED OUR WEBSITE TO TRY TO
MAKE IT EASIER MORE USER
FRIENDLY SO PEOPLE CAN COME AND-
SKATE BECAUSE AS- WE UNDERSTAND
THAT RISKY ACCESS TO YOUR
COMPUTER TO BE ABLE TO GET TO
THAT- WE DO OUTREACH AS THROUGH
THE ADVOCACY COMMUNITY WOULD
PARTNER TRY TO MAINTAIN THIS
OPEN COMMUNICATION. WE ARE IN
FACT KEEPING PEOPLE APPRISED OF
WHAT'S AVAILABLE TO THEM WHAT IT
TAKES TO QUALIFY- AND HOW WE CAN
BE OF ASSISTANCE HI WE HAVE A
COMMUNICATION THAT GOES OUT
MORNING EVERYONE'S CALLED
MORNING COFFEE TO THE ADVOCATE
COMMUNITY IN TRYING TO KIND OF
SHARE THE NEWS OF WHAT'S
AVAILABLE ON A PROGRAM THAT
THESE BENEFITS ARE THERE WE HAVE
SOCIAL MEDIA. OUT REACH OUT BUT
THERE'S ALWAYS GOING TO BE A
NEED TO MAKE THIS COMMUNITY
UNDERSTAND AND KNOW WHAT'S
AVAILABLE TO THEM SO THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE THE BENEFITS I GUESS
THAT RARE IT NINE OUT OF TEN
PEOPLE WHO COME THROUGH OUR
PRIEST. AND THE ONES THAT AREN'T
IT'S TYPICALLY WE CAN'T GET A
HOLD OF FOLKS ARE WE CAN'T GET
THE FOLLOW UP- WE CAN'T GET THE
CONFIRMATION SO- I KNOW THERE'S
AN INTEREST CHECKED FURTHER
HISTORY MEANINGFUL CONVERSATION
THAT'S UNDER WAY ABOUT SOLUTIONS
BUT FOR KALBE C.'S LEAST SPACE
WITHIN THIS I'D. SAY THAT. WE
SHIP THAT WE HAVE. TO PROVIDING
. FINANCIAL AS PEOPLE YOU KNOW
CONVICTED MY- I COME. IT'S NOT
PLACING. IT IS YEAH. LOOK
FORWARD DOING EVERY WE CAN SET.
TO HELP THIS. AND PRETTY IT. OF
ALL THE- PARTIES IN. AND
EVERYONE WHO INTO THIS JUST.
WITH THE INTENT OF MOVING
FORWARD. THANK NOT WE'RE GOING
TO THE TOP PAN SOON EVERYTHING
IN THERE WILL STAY WITH A
QUESTION OUR- AT THE THIS MARINE
THE COR. DOES BILL BLAIR AND
RICHER AND CYNTHIA. IN ANY ORDER
THAT YOU WOULD LIKE. THANKS I'LL
GET STARTED ARE WITH THE A PANEL
YES THANK YOU NATALIE I MEAN
MARIN WAS QUEEN. THANK YOU AND
GOOD MORNING JOE SAWYER THANK
CHAIRMAN LACKEY AND ASSEMBLY. I
AM WITH. A STUDENT HER WITH THE
INTERNET HUMAN RIGHTS CLINIC AT
THE U. S. SEQUEL SCHOOL OF LAW.
ON NOVEMBER FIFTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE OUR CLINIC PUBLISHED
ONE OF THE FIRST COMPREHENSIVE
REPORTS ABOUT US ANTI SEX
TRAFFICKING LAW ENFORCEMENT
OPERATIONS. THESE OPERATIONS
OFTEN REFERRED TO AS RAIDS
STINGS ARE SWEEPS INVOLVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT WORKING UNDER COVER
OR INVESTIGATING PRIVATE
ESTABLISHMENTS TO IDENTIFY
TRAFFICKED PERSONS AND
PERPETRATORS. WE STARTED OUR
INVESTIGATION IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN- WE ARE PROMPTED BY A
LACK OF PUBLICLY AVAILABLE DATA
REGARDING LAW ENFORCEMENT ANTI
SEX TRAFFICKING OPERATIONS SO IN
ABOUT AN EFFORT TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THESE OPERATIONS WE
CONDUCTED A COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW
OF RELEVANT LITERATURE. WE
INTERVIEWED FORTY TWO
PROFESSIONALS IN THE ANTI HUMAN
TRAFFICKING FIELD INCLUDING
FEDERAL AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT FEDERAL LOCAL
PROSECUTORS LAW ENFORCEMENT
ADVOCATES NONPROFIT ADVOCATES
EXPERTS AND SURVIVOR ADVOCATES.
WE ALSO FILED SIXTEEN FEDERAL
AND STATE PUBLIC RECORDS
REQUESTS UNDER THE FREEDOM OF
INFORMATION ACT AND THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC RECORDS ACT.
WE FOCUSED OUR STATE DATA
COLLECTION ON CALIFORNIA FOR TWO
MAIN REASONS FIRST GIVEN THE
LOCATION OF THE INTERNATIONAL
HUMAN RIGHTS CLINIC AT USC IN
LOS ANGELES MOST OF THE CLINIC'S
EXPERTISE AND CONTACTS ARE IN
CALIFORNIA. SECOND UNIQUE
FEATURES OF ANTI SEX TRAFFICKING
EFFORTS IN CALIFORNIA MAKE THE
STATE AN INTERESTING CASE STUDY
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS ONE OF THE
HIGHEST RATES OF SEX TRAFFICKING
IN THE U. S. HAS IMPLEMENTED
PROGRESSIVE LEGISLATION AGAINST
HUMAN TRAFFICKING. AND IS MODEL
THAT STATEWIDE ANTI TRAFFICKING
OPERATION CALLED OPERATION
RECLAIM AND REBUILD AFTER
FEDERAL OPERATIONS SUCH AS THE
INNOCENCE LOST INITIATIVE. I
TURN TO OUR MAIN CONCLUSIONS. IN
OUR INVESTIGATION WE HEARD
ENCOURAGING REPORTS OF THESE
OPERATIONS BECOMING MORE
EFFECTIVE AND MORE TRAUMA
INFORMED OVERTIME. HOWEVER THE
LITERATURE IN INTERVIEWS ALSO
CONSISTENTLY INDICATED THAT
THESE RATES ARE NOT THE BEST
SOLUTIONS TO HELP PEOPLE WHO ARE
BEING TRAFFICKED AND ALTERNATIVE
APPROACHES COULD BETTER PROTECT
VICTIMS STILL TAKE PROSECUTION
OF TRAFFICKERS AND PREVENT
TRAFFICKING. THE LITERATURE
SUGGESTS THAT OPERATIONS
IDENTIFY A FEW PEOPLE WHO ARE
BEING TRAFFICKED EMPHASIZING THE
OPERATIONS PRIMARILY TARGET SEX
WORK AND TOO OFTEN TREAT VICTIMS
PARTICULARLY BLACK VICTIMS AS
CRIMINALS. WE HAVE REPORTS IN
BOTH OUR INTERVIEWS AND
LITERATURE THAT SOME OFFICERS TO
CONDUCT OPERATIONS RECEIVED
INSUFFICIENT VICTIM
IDENTIFICATION TRAINING. THE
LITERATURE ALSO INDICATES THAT
OPERATIONS ARE SOMETIMES
CONDUCTED WITH INSUFFICIENT PRE
OPERATION INVESTIGATION OR
WITHOUT EVIDENCE THAT THERE IS
EITHER A MINOR INVOLVED BUT THAT
THERE'S FORCE FRAUD AND COERCION
INVOLVED. SIMILARLY OUR
INTERVIEWS REPORTED THAT AND
THEIR EXPERIENCE OPERATIONS TEND
TO IDENTIFY FEW OR NO
TRAFFICKERS AND ARE EXECUTED
WITH INSUFFICIENT EVIDENCE TO
ARREST TRAFFICKERS AND
OPERATIONS UNDERMINE REPORT WITH
PEOPLE WHO ARE BEING TRAFFICKED
IN LINE FOR CEMENT. WHICH TENDS
TO BE CRUCIAL TO SECURE
TESTIMONY NECESSARY TO PROSECUTE
TRAFFICKERS. AND EXPERT
EXPLAINED THAT EVEN WITH THE
BEST MOST TRAUMA INFORMED
QUESTIONING PROTOCOLS THAT WE
SOMETIMES SEE SELF
IDENTIFICATION OF VICTIMS DURING
OR IMMEDIATELY AFTER OPERATIONS
REMAINS UNLIKELY AND I CAN BE
BECAUSE OF THE ACUTE STRESS OF
THE SITUATION OR A DISTRUST OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE BEING TRAFFICKED.
QUESTIONING DURING THIS TIME CAN
ALSO BE TRAUMATIZING FOR VICTIMS
IN ADDITION TO APPROVING
EFFECTIVE. I'M INTERVIEWING
LETTER DESCRIBED COURSE IN
OFFICE SOMETIMES FOREGOING
VICTIM CENTERED APPROACHES
DURING OPERATIONS AND INSTEAD
ARRESTING OR THREATEN TO ARREST
INTERROGATING DOWNING ARE
DOUBTING. BLAMING AND
MISGENDERING TRAFFICKED PERSONS
ON SOME OCCASIONS. TRAFFICKING
SURVIVORS IN THE LITERATURE OF
DESCRIBED REYES IS CHAOTIC AND
OFTEN TRAUMATIC EVENTS THAT
WE'VE BEEN FRIGHTENED OR
CONFUSED WITH NO SENSE OF WHAT
WAS HAPPENING OR WHAT HAPPENED
TO THEM. AND A FEW VICTIMS
IDENTIFIED DURING OPERATIONS
MIGHT FACE POTENTIAL
IMPRISONMENT ON THE BASIS OF A
MATERIAL WITNESS WARRANT OR
CRIMINAL CHARGE. A LAW
ENFORCEMENT INVESTIGATOR WE
INTERVIEWED RECOUNTED CHASING
TRAFFICKED PERSONS DOWN THE
HALLWAY OF HOTELS DURING
OPERATIONS. AND HAVING ARMED
SECURITY AT THE DOOR. A PUBLIC
HEALTH I TO SEXUAL ABUSE BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT DURING OPERATIONS AS
PART OF THE TRAUMA OF BEING
TRAFFICKED. THE NONPROFIT
ADVOCATE WE INTERVIEWED
DESCRIBED RAIDS AND NOT A PLACE
WHERE YOU'RE RESTORING AUTONOMY
TO SURVIVORS. ONE INTERVIEWING
NOTED THAT ETHNIC DENTS HAVE TO
BE HANDCUFFED AND POTENTIALLY
INJURED TO BE HELPED PERHAPS
OPERATIONS ARE NOT THE BEST WAY
TO IDENTIFY AND INTERACT WITH
PEOPLE WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
TRACKING. INDEED ONE OFFICER IN
LITERATURE DESCRIBED QUOTE. WE
ALMOST HAVE TO DO HE SAME
GROOMING PROCESS THAT DEPENDED.
A LOT OF TIMES THE VICTIMS ARE
VERY ANGRY YOU KNOW THEY DON'T
WANT TO BE PICKED UP ON CLOUT.
DURING CERTAIN OPERATIONS
UNDERCOVER OFFICERS INITIALLY
POSED AS BUYERS LATER SURPRISING
VICTIMS OFTEN ABRUPTLY AND
WITHOUT WARNING WHAT THEIR TRUE
IDENTITY. ONE SURVIVOR WE
INTERVIEWED COMPARED THAT
DECEPTION BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
WITH HOW TRAFFICKERS MISLEAD
THEIR VICTIMS WITH PROMISES OF
MONEY LOVE AND SECURITY ONLY TO
SURPRISE THEM WITH THE HARSH
REALITY OF BEING TRAFFICKED.
SURVIVORS SAID QUOTE TRAFFICKERS
ARE OFTEN MAIL AND HAVE A
POSITION OF POWER. TRAFFICKERS
OF CHECKING COERCED THEM INTO
TRUSTING THEM WHEN YOU HAVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHO HAS DONE THE
SAME THING SAID I'M THE BUYER
AND THEN NOPE I'M ARRESTING YOU.
THEY CHECKED ON LIKE THE
TRAFFICKER UNQUOTE. AN
INVESTIGATOR WE INTERVIEWED
EXPRESSING FRUSTRATION WITH
VICTIMS RELUCTANCE TO GET
INFORMATION. ALSO STATED THAT
THEY WILL SOMETIMES QUESTION
PEOPLE WHO ARE BEING TRAFFICKED
UNTIL THEY BREAK. FINALLY
REGARDING OUR CONCLUSIONS
OPERATIONS DO NOT ADDRESS
FACTORS THAT MAKE PEOPLE
VULNERABLE TO BEING TRAFFICKED
AND ROUTINELY FAIL TO CONNECT
SURVIVORS WITH THE SHORT AND
LONG TERM SERVICES THAT ARE
CRITICAL TO STABILIZATION AND
PREVENTION EVERY TRAFFICKING.
OPERATIONS THAT DO NOT ALLOW
PERSONS WERE BEING TRAFFICKED TO
CHOOSE WHETHER WHEN AND HOW THEY
INTERACT WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
CAN UNINTENTIONALLY REINFORCE
THIS TRAFFICKERS NARRATIVE THAT
WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING. THE
NARRATIVE ABOUT LAW ENFORCEMENT
. ALL THESE FACTORS CONTRIBUTE
INDIRECTLY TO SUPPORTING THE
TRAFFICKERS ABILITY TO CONTROL
AND COURSE VICTIMS ENEMIES WAYS
L. PLANNED OPERATION BETTER NOT
TRAUMA INFORMED ARE MORE LIKELY
TO PERPETUATE THEM PREVENT SEX
TRAFFICKING AND SYNDICATIONS.
OUR INVESTIGATION ALSO
IDENTIFIED ALTERNATIVE
APPROACHES TO ANTI SEX
TRAFFICKING OPERATIONS WHICH BY
CENTERING SURVIVOR AUTONOMY WE
CAN BETTER IDENTIFICATION OF
TRAFFIC PERSONS AND BETTER
OUTCOMES FOR SURVIVORS- IS A
PURCHASE ANTI TRAFFICKING
EFFORTS ARE TRENDING AWAY FROM
USE OF OPERATIONS RATE STINGS
AND SWEET. AND FOCUSING INSTEAD
ON COMMUNITY INVOLVEMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH AND HARM REDUCTION
STRATEGIES AND INVESTMENTS IN
POVERTY RELIEF ANTI
DISCRIMINATION INITIATIVES AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EDUCATION AND
MPLOYMENT. AS SUCH A REPORT
RECOMMENDS THAT FUNDING SHOULD
BE USED TO INCREASE THE
AVAILABILITY OF VICTIM SERVICES.
INCLUDING SHELTER SPECIFICALLY
FOR TRAFFICKING VICTIMS LONG
TERM HOUSING WHICH MANY OF OUR
INTERVIEWEES IDENTIFIED AS THE
MOST CRUCIAL SERVICE. MENTAL
HEALTH COUNSELING IMMIGRATION
SERVICES LEGAL SERVICES
EDUCATION AID JOB TRAINING
PROGRAMS LIFE SKILLS TRAINING.
SUBSTANCE ABUSE PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES FOR THE CHILDREN OF
TRAFFIC PERSONS. TO SUPPORT THIS
AFTER LAW ENFORCEMENT SHOULD
BUILD ITS RELATIONSHIPS WITH
COMMUNITY NONPROFITS TO CREATE A
NETWORK THAT CAN EFFECTIVELY
PROVIDE VICTIMS WITH A WELL
ROUNDED SET OF SERVICES
INCLUDING HOUSING. THREE BASIC
NEEDS SUCH AS FOOD AND CLOTHING
CRISIS UNTIL HEALTH COUNSELING
AS I MENTIONED IMMIGRATION
SERVICES LEGAL AID SERVICES
EDUCATION JOB TRAINING AMONG
OTHERS. A FEDERAL PROSECUTOR WE
INTERVIEWED AND DISCUSSING THE
LINK BETWEEN TRAFFICKING AND
NEGLECTED CHILDREN SHARED QUOTE
WE CAN GET BETTER AT
UNDERSTANDING HOW RECRUITMENT
HAPPENS AND POOL INTELLIGENCE TO
DEVELOP BETTER WAYS TO PROTECT
PEOPLE. IN THE MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS. HELLO ENFORCEMENT I
WE A STATING. WHERE IT IS GO AND
BOYS BEING FROM. AND HOW DO YOU
STOP IT AND DO YOU SEEIT HOW DO
YOU COMMUTE YOUR- TO PROTECT THE
CHILDREN IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
THERE'S ONLY SO MUCH THE COPS
CAN DO AND FOR SOME OF THESE
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR COPS ARE
NOT THE ANSWER. AND QUOTE. WE
ENCOURAGE THIS COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT COMMUNITY AND PUBLIC
HEALTH APPROACHES TO IDENTIFY
VICTIMS AND TRAFFICKERS OUTSIDE
OF THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THAT APPROACH REQUIRES
SYSTEMATICALLY COLLECTING DATA
RELATED TO EXPLOITATION.
RESEARCHING TOPICS INCLUDING
VICTIMIZATION RISK FACTORS AND
IMPLEMENTING PROGRAMS FOR
PREVENTING TRAFFICKING AND
IDENTIFYING TRAFFICKING IN ITS
EARLY STAGES. PART OF THIS
APPROACH ENTAILS TRAINING
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS LIKE
PHYSICIANS EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
WORKERS AND SOCIAL WORKERS TO
IDENTIFY THE SIGNS OF
TRAFFICKING IN PATIENTS AND TO
OFFER RESOURCES TO SUSPECTED
VICTIMS. OF FOR EXAMPLETHE SAN
FRANCISCO DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH DISSEMINATES INFORMATION
TO WORKERS IN MASSAGE
ESTABLISHMENTS ABOUT ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE. AND DIGNITY HEALTH
A NONPROFIT THAT OPERATES
HOSPITALS IN CALIFORNIA ARIZONA
AND NEVADA HIGHER SURVIVOR
ADVOCATES TO WORK IN HOSPITALS
SINCE THEY FEEL THAT SURVIVORS
MAYBE MORE SUPPORTED AND
EMPOWERED BY OTHER SURVIVORS
DONE BY LAW ENFORCEMENT OR
DIFFERENT TYPES OF PROFESSIONALS
. SINCE THE PUBLICATION OF A
REPORT WE'VE ALSO BEEN GRATIFIED
BY FARTHER OUT OF REACH FROM THE
ANTI TRAFFICKING COMMUNITY
INCLUDING ADVOCATES IN OREGON
WHO DESCRIBE OPERATIONAL
PROCESSES WHERE SURVIVOR
ADVOCATES AND DEFENSE ATTORNEYS
ARE ALWAYS ON SITE TO MEET WITH
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE BEEN
TRAFFICKED. LASTED ABOUT ONE
LOCAL OFFICER WE INTERVIEWED THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF ANTI SEX
TRAFFICKING EFFORTS QUOTE COMES
DOWN TO PUBLIC AWARENESS.
COMMUNITY NEEDS TO BE MORE
EDUCATED ABOUT WHAT'S OCCURRING
AND HOW PARENTS CAN BE EFFECTIVE
AT PROTECTING THEIR KIDS. TO
THAT END WE RECOMMEND BOWSTRING
PREVENTION EFFORTS THAT REDUCE
THE VULNERABILITY OF POTENTIAL
VICTIMS AND TRAFFICKERS. FOR
EXAMPLE ADVANCING RESEARCH ABOUT
SEX TRAFFICKING RECRUITMENT
STRATEGIES AND FACTORS THAT
INCREASE VULNERABILITY TO
TRAFFICKING. THIS RESEARCH
APPEARS TO STRENGTHEN EARLY
INTERVENTION PROGRAMS WHICH
INVOLVES RAISING COMMUNITY
AWARENESS AND EDUCATING YOUTH
ABOUT HEALTHY INTERPERSONAL
RELATIONSHIPS AND THE NATURE OF
SEXUAL EXPLOITATION. I ONE SUCH
STRATEGIES FOR SCHOOLS TO
IMPLEMENT AS PART OF A BASIC
CURRICULUM AT THE ELEMENTARY AND
MIDDLE SCHOOL LEVEL. LESSONS
ABOUT THE EXISTENCE OF
TRAFFICKING THE RIGHT OF
STUDENTS TO HEALTHY NON CORE
CIRCULATION CHIPS AND HOW TO
IDENTIFY AND SEEK HELP FROM
TRUSTWORTHY ADULTS. AS PART OF A
TWENTY EIGHTEEN STUDY OF
SURVIVORS IN THE MIDWEST RAJARAM
IN TEN BALL CONDUCT INTERVIEWS
SURVIVORS MANY OF WHOM
RECOMMENDED THAT ONE WAY TO
SUPPORT VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS.
IS TO EDUCATE THEM FROM AN EARLY
AGE ABOUT. THE DANGERS AND
WARNING SIGNS OF TRAFFICKING.
RAISING ON ABOUT SUCH
TRAFFICKING ENABLES COMMUNITY
MEMBERS TO IDENTIFY AT RISK YOU.
PROVIDE THEM WITH ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTS AND PROMPTLY REPORT
EVIDENCE OF TRAFFICKING ITSELF.
UNLIKE THE SHORTCOMINGS OF
VICTIM IDENTIFICATION DURING
OPERATIONS THAT ARE OFTEN
CHAOTIC IS COMMUNITY LED
APPROACHES BUILD RAPPORT WITH
VICTIMS WHICH IN TURN MAKES
VICTIMS MORE LIKELY TO DISCLOSE
INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR TRACKING
SITUATION WHICH AIMS PROSECUTION
OF TRAFFICKERS. THESE APPROACHES
ARE LAST HARMFUL TO VICTIMS
BECAUSE THEY ALLOW VICTIMS TO
MAINTAIN THEIR AGENCY
COMMUNICATE WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
ON THEIR OWN TERMS AND THEY DO
NOT RE TRAUMATIZE VICTIMS IN A
WAY THAT OPERATIONS OFTEN DO.
ACCORDING TO JIM STRICKER AND A
TWENTY EIGHTEEN STUDY OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AS A PUBLIC HEALTH
ISSUE QUOTE. HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS CHILD WELFARE WORKERS
HOME CARE WORKERS. LEADERS LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSON ON SOCIAL
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND VIRTUALLY
EVERYONE ELSE WHO COMES IN
CONTACT WITH THOSE WHO MAY BE AT
RISK OF BEING TRAFFICKED CAN
COMMUNICATE. PRIMARY PREVENTION
FOCUSED MESSAGES THAT STRENGTHEN
INDIVIDUAL KNOWLEDGE AND SKILLS
AND QUOTE. FINALLY WE RECOMMEND
INVESTING IN ANTI POVERTY
EFFORTS ANY DISCRIMINATION
EFFORTS AND EDUCATIONAL AND
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES. IN THE
SAME JIM STRICKER STUDY THE
AUTHORS EXPLAIN CORE ECONOMIC
LEGAL AND SOCIAL FACTORS
INCLUDING POVERTY DISCRIMINATION
AN ADEQUATE EDUCATION AND
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES. AND
INSUFFICIENT PROTECTIONS FOR
WORKERS MUST ALL BE ADDRESSED IN
ORDER TO ELIMINATE AND REDUCE
TRAFFICKING AND QUOTE. WELL I.
DRESSING THE SYSTEMIC ISSUES IS
NO SIMPLE FEAT MONEY TO PREVENT
TRAFFICKING MAY BE BETTER SPENT
FOR OPERATIONS THAT ARE FROM
PREMATURELY AND FORCIBLY REMOVE
THAT TENSION OR TRACKING
SITUATION. WITH NO VIABLE.
ALTERNATIVE AN INSUFFICIENT
SOCIAL SUPPORT THAT MONEY WOULD
BE BETTER SPENT ADDRESSING THE
SYSTEMIC ISSUES. USING THESE NON
. COMMUTER BASED. TO ANTI
TRAFFICKING CENTER SURVIVOR
AUTONOMY AND BETTER SELF
IDENTIFICATION AND OUTCOMES FOR
SURVIVORS RESULT. WE URGE THIS
COMMITTEE TO EMBRACE THESE
APPROACHES AND MOVE AWAY FROM
ONE PERSON OPERATIONS I THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND
WELCOME YOUR QUESTIONS AFTER MY
FELLOW PANELISTS HAVE SPOKEN.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BEGIN. THANK
YOU AND GOOD MORNING HI MY NAME
IS JOSEPH OFTHE GEL OF THE
DIRECTOR OF POLICY AT THIS A
GAME. AND TO HUMAN TRAFFIC. YES
THIS BETTER GO THANK YOU- AGAIN
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JOSEPH
GALLAGHER PAULA AT THIS A JANE
AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING POLICY NAY
HELLO SCHOOL THIS HEARING COMES
THE HEELS OF CELL HIM
TRAFFICKING AWARENESS MONTH AND
SO WE FOR THAT WE APPRECIATE THE
CHAIR AND THE STAFF ARE WORKING
TOWARDS CREATING A SPACE THAT
BRINGS EXPERTS ACROSS DIFFERENT
SECTORS TO PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO ENSURE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE TAKES A
COMPREHENSIVE AN INTERSECTIONAL
APPROACH TO ADDRESS ALL FORMS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY TO PROVIDE A VEHICLE
FOR IMPACTED INDIVIDUALS TO
SHARE THE POWERFUL STORIES. MY
REMARKS WILL GENERALLY TIED ON
FOUR POINTS ONE AND APPROACH
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS TAKEN
IN THE PAST DECADE. ALSO CA ST
LAWS THE LACK FOR IMPLEMENT. I'M
I WILL URGE- THIS COMMITTEE AND
THE LEGISLATURE DUE TO MOVE
POLICIES THAT HAVE TO BE CENTER
ON ON SURVIVALS. AND LACK AND
LASTLY ALSO- SUBMIT TO YOU THAT
THERE IS A LACK OF LONG TERM
VISION TO ADDRESS HUMAN
TRAFFICKING FROM CALIFORNIA.
MOREOVER HAVE EVERY POOR CAN
RECENT REPORT BY THE STATE
DEPARTMENT PUBLISHED IN JULY OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE FOUND THAT THE
PANDEMIC HAS PLACE VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES MORE AYE REYES OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING. AND IN SOME
CASES RESULTED IN DECREASED OF
INDIA LOCATION OF RESOURCES TO
ASSIST VICTIMS BUT THEN ALSO TO
CONTACT HUMAN TRAFFICKING. MY
PREVIOUS COMMENTS SHED LIGHT ON
THE FACT THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
MADE SOME PROGRESS ABOUT WHAT WE
ARE REALLY FAR FROM JULIET
RESTING HUMAN TRAFFICKING. THE
APPROACH THAT OUR STATE HAS
TAKEN IN THE PAST DECADE IS
ENOUGH FOR SPENT ONLY AND
DETERRENCE ONLY APPROACH THAT TO
SOME EXTENT HAS WORK. BUT ALSO A
LACKS AN UNDERSTANDING OF THE
COMPLEXITIES OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. HOWEVER THESE BODY
BUT AND THIS COMMITTEE HAS
SHIFTED THAT MENTALITY AND HAS
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT THIS APPROACH
IS INSUFFICIENT. AND THAT
SURVIVORS NEED MORE THAN OUR
PRAYERS AND GOOD INTENTIONS. TO
THAT END THE LEGISLATURE HAS
INCREASED SERVICES- THE VICTIMS.
OF FOR INSTANCE IN THE LAST
BUDGET THANK DOZEN MEMBERS SAN
DIEGO- THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
WERE ALLOCATED TO ENSURE THAT.
SERVICE PROVIDERS WERE CONTINUE
TO OPEN THE DOORS TO REGARDLESS
OF WHERE WE WERE IN THE PEOPLE
CONTINUE TO BE AND THE PANDEMIC
. I HAVE FOR THEIR MORE- THIS
HIS NATION HAS ALL PRO RELIEF
FOR DOORS. ARE VICTIMS WHO WERE
CAUGHT- URGED TO DO ACTIVITIES
THAT LED TO AN OFFENSE IN THE
RECORDS. THERE'S A LOT MORE WORK
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE THERE BUT
A MINIMUM TO HAS BEEN
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT THERE HAS TO
BE A WAY TO BY KATE THOSE
RECORDS. ALSO THERE HAS BEEN
SOME EFFORTS TO ENSURE THAT. WE
GO AND TRYING TO PREVENT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AT EARLY AGE- BY. AT
FORMER HUSBAND MEMBER BONTA OUT
YOU NEED TO PASS A BILL THAT UP
A- VERGE PROFESSIONALS IN K. TO
TWELVE TO BE TRAINED AND THEN
PROVIDE AWARENESS TO MINORS
ABOUT HUMAN TRAFFICKING. THIS
POINT IS IMPORTANT AS ALL NINE
RECRUITMENT BY HUMAN TRAFFICKING
HAS INCREASED BY ABOUT 22% IN
THE LAST YEAR'S. LASTLY THE
LEGISLATURE HAS ALSO MADE
PROGRESS TO ENSURE THE LABOR
TRAFFICKING HE'S ALSO
PRIORITIZE. DO THAT AND HE
PROVIDED THE AUTHORITY TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING TO INVESTIGATE A
COMEBACK LABOR TRAFFICKING.
HOWEVER THESE POLICIES HOW
FALLING SHORT MOSTLY BECAUSE OF
LACK OF FUNDING AND
PRIORITIZATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE. AB IT IS FOUR DOT
THAT REASON THAT WE ARE
REQUESTING A FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET ALLOCATION- AND
ALSO SEEKING LEGISLATIVE CHANGES
IN THE AREAS OF LABOR- LAW BUT
THEN ALSO TO PROVIDE RELIEF FOR
VICTIMS WITH SOME OFFENSES. I
PROPOSAL WHICH YOU KNOW YOU HAVE
IN YOUR PACKAGE IS A ONE TIME
ALLOCATION OF FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS THAT ARE FOR RESEARCH
WITH HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING EDUCATION AND
PREVENTION. THESE ONE TIME A
LOCATION FUNDING WILL FUND THE
FOLLOWING ONE THE PREVALENCE
STUDY TO UNDERSTAND THE EXTENT
LOCATION AND DEMOGRAPHICS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING IN CALIFORNIA.
TO PROVIDE TRAINING AND
TECHNICAL RESOURCES TO SERVICE
OUR SERVICE PROVIDERS. THREE
MAKE SURE THAT THE ANKLE THE
CURRENT LAW- THAT IS IN PLACE I
HAS FUNDING IN DAYS MEANS THAT
PROVIDE I'M GOING CURRICULA
FOCUS A FUNDING TO COMBAT
COMMAND TRAFFICKING IN K. TO
TWELVE- FOR- MAKE SURE THAT WE
FIND AN AVERAGE PROGRAM. WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING WHICH HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO COME BACK LABOR
TRAFFICKING AND YET THEY'RE
LACKING FUNDING TO IMPLEMENT
THAT LAW SINCE TWO THOUSAND SIX
SIXTY. LAST ALSO DEDICATED AND
IT AND FIND A TASK FORCE WITHIN
AT THE I. R. DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIALRELATIONS ARE TO
FIGHT OUT- AN INVESTIGATIVE OR
TRAFFIC IN. AB FOR THE PAST
THREE YEARS AND YOU WILL HAVE A
SPEAKER DON'T SPEAK ON THE
REPORTS FROM THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION AND AT THE THIS
COMMISSION HAS ISSUED THREE
REPORTS AND HAS DONE THIS
EXTENSIVE RESEARCH IN REGARDS TO
HUMAN TRAFFICKING THE PATTERN
THAT COMES OUT OF THOSE REPORTS
IS THAT THE STATE HAS TO DO MORE
WORK AS RELATES TO LABOR
TRAFFICKING IT IS FOR THAT
REASON THAT WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR
US ADULT ARAMBULA COOL BE AT
INTRODUCED AND I THREE AT A BILL
THAT WE CALLED AND THE LABOR
TRAFFICKING ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. WHICH I WOULD ALLOW ME
PROVIDE AT THIRTY TO DEPARTMENT
OF INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS TO
INVESTIGATE A COME BACK LABOR
TRAFFICKING THE SAME WAY THAT
APARTMENT A FRIEND HOUSING HAS
THAT AUTHORITY AS WELL- THE
OTHER. BILL THAT ALSO TRYING IT
AT. WILL BE. IT IS FOR. TO
ENSURE THAT VICTIMS WHO ARE- YOU
ARE A VICTIM OF TRAFFICKING WHO
ARE MY- HAVE ALL AND ARE VICTIMS
OF THE ATTACK. HAVE ALSO ACCESS
TO THE RESOURCES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO THEM AND TO THAT
END WE ARE INTRODUCING A BILL-
AND ASSEMBLY THAT MAJORITY
LEADER- RADIUS WILL BE OUT THERE
IN THAT BILL- THIS BILL SEEKS TO
ENSURE. THAT ND CLARIFY THE
CURRENT STATUTE- RELATED TO-
CHILD ABUSE I ALSO INCLUDES
LABOR TRAFFICKING AB SO THAT
BOTH SIX AND LABOR TRAFFIC YOU
TO RECEIVE THE SAME SUPPORT AND
PROTECTION IS THAT THEY ARE
CURRENTLY ARE ABLE OR HAVE UNDER
CURRENT STATUTES YET LABOR
TRAFFICKING OF MINORS AT TIMES
ARE NOT IDENTIFIED- TO THE
PROFESSIONALS BECAUSE THERE IS A
LACK OF UNDERSTANDING OF THAT.
OF THAT POPULATION. I'M LASTLY
WILL SAY THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS PROVIDED RELIEF TO VICTIMS
THAT WERE CARS AGAIN TO
PARTICIPATE IN CRIMINAL
ACTIVITIES AFFECT IN THEIR
RECORDS AND HAPPENED ABILITY TO
BECOME SELF SUFFICIENT- WE
APPRECIATE AS A MEMBER GIVE
STUFF WILL BE OUT THERE IN THE
BILL. THE TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CLARIFY THAT THAT'S THAT
YOU ALSO. APPLIES TO NOT
CITIZENS THERE IS A VAGUE
LANGUAGE RIGHT NOW AND WE HOPE
THAT THAT BILL ALSO MAKE IT TO
THE TO THE PROCESS. AGAIN WE
THANK THIS COMMITTEE FOR SEEKING
THE INPUT ON THE FACT THAT
INDIVIDUALS BUT THEN ALSO
EXPERTS FROM ACROSS THE SECTOR
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE TACKLE
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND A
COMPREHENSIVE. AN INTERSECTIONAL
APPROACH THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NOT RICH. I AM PROFESSOR
STEPHANIE RICHARD WITH LAW
SCHOOL AND THE DRINK DIRECTOR OF
THE AND FORCED PRO. DIRECTLY
CERTAIN CRIMES I'M ALSO A SENIOR
POLICY ADVISER TO THE CEO JANE
ANTI TRAFFICKING INITIATIVES I
WORKED ON TRAFFICKING ISSUES
SINCE TWO THOUSAND TWO AND AN
INVOLVED THREE REAUTHORIZATION
OF FEDERAL TRAFFICKING VICTIMS
PROTECTION ACT I'VE ALSO BEEN
INVOLVED IN SEEING THE AFTERMATH
OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST OFF SETTING
HIGHER CRIMINAL PENALTIES FOR
HUMAN TRAFFICKING. THOUSAND FIVE
WROTE A LAW REVIEW ARTICLE AHEAD
OF IT LEGISLATION DIFFERENT
TRAFFICKING HELPFUL OR HARMFUL
THAT'S HOW 500-003-0005 MULTIPLE
STATES PASSWORD THAT FOCUSED ON
CRIMINALIZING TRAFFIC WE ALL
MAKE THE NOT ADDRESS AND
INCREASED RESOURCES THE ISSUE
PROVIDED ANY THESE PROTECTIONS
TO SURVIVORS HELLO AFTER YOU IN
TRAFFIC. EXCEPT VIOLIN APPROACH. LATER WE ARE STILL TAKING A
APPROACH. IN TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
TEN I WORK WITH ACTORS THE HUMAN
CRY. YOU KNOW WORK IS THE
MYSTICAL. AS WELL INTERNET WE-
INCLUDING SURVIVOR LEADERS CRAFT
I JUST AGENDA THAT WOULD PREVENT
TRAFFICKING PEOPLE PARTS.
EXAGGERATE CORD WITHIN TEN YEARS
THE- AGENDA WAS THE- ONLY SMALL
PIECE HAVE BEEN. AND CAL. AND
TRAFFICKING WAS EASIER FROM WE
HAVE WE WILL HAVE DONE IF NOW WE
NEVER BE ABLE TO. WAY I OF THIS
IS. COME BACK HUMAN TAKES
CREATIVE ON OFF ENGAGES THE
AFTER ARE STANDING STILL. OKAY
EACH OR OR RE- CALIFORNIA WAS
THE TAKE FIRST THAT'S AT NUMBER
EXPERTS AS AT AGREED TO FOLLOW
MUST BE DONE. FIRST WE CAN ONLY
PREVENT BY BRING RESOURCE THE
ISSUE AFTER. HELLO THE LAST
YEARS HELLO. ONLY FROM SPECIAL
RESPONSE WRITTEN THIS IS A-
PURPOSES NO MONEY AND ALLOCATED
YOU TRY TO PREVENT TRACK WE'VE
IT STARTS. REYES I NEVER STUDIES
YOU KNOW WHAT LOOKS LIKE OUR
STATE NOT BEEN FUNDED. THANK
OTHER THERE'S BEEN SOME YEARS
ADVOCATE AROUND THE. J.
TRAFFICKING READ OR LAW
ENFORCEMENT EFFORT OPERATION
COST HOW MANY VICTIMS ARE
IDENTIFIED YOU THAT PROCESS. IN
COMPARISON TO HOW MUCH IS A
COMMUNITY BASED TRAUMA AND
FORWARD. HELP OUT REACHED OUT
FOR COSTS AND HOW WE- I WATER WE
INVEST YOU IN THOSE OF NOW- AND
OUR LOW AT THE KEY FOR A- CALL.
THE SECOND QUESTION WE NEED TO
URGE LAUNCH PARTNERS TO WITH IT
THEY CAN. TO WHO- HAVE LONG FOR
OPERATIONS A PRIMARY WHERE THAT
IF ON IDENTIFYING BIG DUMB WHAT
ARE THE QUESTION WHY SHOULD
THEIR BUDGET NOW INCLUDING. THE
RESOURCES NEEDED TO HOW
SHELTERED PROVIDE THE WRAPAROUND
SERVICES- OR SURVIVORS THE FAT
YOU DON'T CAN TO WERE THAN THE
ARE NOT WE ARE NOW. IN OUR
SERVICE I FOR ARE WE NEARLY
FORCED PARTNERS TO EACH. YOU
SERVICES AS A MUCH WHICH REMAINS
BUDGETS FOR ONE OR- SECOND FOR
READING TO AT OUR TOP WELFARE
SYSTEM TO PROP RISK TO OLD
SCHOOL TRAFFIC HE PICKED UP SAID
ASSEMBLY BIRCH BANK RELATED
DIFFERENT. EARLY ON A FIRE TO
AND A SPECIAL THOSE FOR INTO
CRIMINAL ACTS WHETHER IN OR SEX. ATTACKERS I. GOVERNOR AS A
BIRDS VETO ELLEN CAL WILL. HAVE
DONE JUST THAT. AND THUS FAR
STAY HIS OWN TAKEN. ABSTRACT SEX. TRAFFIC CALIFORNIA ALSO
INTERNATIONALLY HOWEVER. LED THE
WAY EMPATHIC SB FIVE AND TEN IN
IMPLEMENT THIS IS YOUR- THANK
YOU OF THE TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN. THE CALIFORNIA
PROCEDURE OFFICE THIS HAD ACT
INTO. AND WITH OTHER CA ALWAYS.
AND ACTION STARTING THE BATTLE.
AROUND AND TAKE EFFORTS IT WILL
IT'S PAST HOWEVER THE
LEGISLATURE HAS NO ADDITIONAL
STOPS. JOHNSON TO A IN. AYE
AGAIN YOU CAN TRY. ACCORDING
LEGISLATION LOOKED AT. EUROPE
POLICIES THAT INTRODUCED AT THIS
TIME. HAS NEVER BEEN REINTRODUCE. LASTLY EX AGREE THAT A TO
PROVIDE TRAFFIC YOU'VE READ
STARTS BY. REGULAR FOR LABOR.
IT'S BECAUSE THEIR POWER. WRITER
NASH WRITER ON THE THIRDS OF. ON
THAT WERE IN. YES BOB WE ARE.
TOP ST FRANCIS. THE SIMPSONS ARE
. VICTOR WAS. BROTHER TO OUR
STATE. IS A LEADER IN PROTECTING
VICTIMS BUT ALSO IN THE NEED FOR
THESE PROTECTIONS WHAT WAS
INTERESTING IDEAS BUT A LARGE
ATTENDS OUR ACCOUNT A PERCENT OF
THOSE GRANTED TV SAYS THE
FIGHTERS VICTIMS OF TRAFFICKING
WHERE THOSE CAME TO THE U. S. IS
THAT. AS PREVENT TRAFFICKING WE
RECRUIT CALIFORNIA HAS A CHANCE
TO LEAD THE WAY IN DOING JUST
THAT ENSURING THAT AB THREE SIX
FOUR RODRIGUEZ REACHES THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK THIS YEAR INSIDE
THE BOX AB THREE SIX FOUR TAKES
A PROVIDED APPROACH PROVIDE
PRIDING PROTECTIONS TO WORKERS
AT THE WE RECRUITMENT CURRENTLY
REGULATION OF TEMPORARY BASIC
CATEGORIES IS FRAGMENTED
FEDERALLY. ARE STATE ONCE AND
LABOR THIS IS A STORAGE
OVERSIGHT MEANS UNSCRUPULOUS
RECRUITERS ARE EASILY ABLE TO
CONTINUE FRAUDULENT PRACTICES
ACROSS ALL THESE CATEGORIES
DIRECT ABUSE HOW FRIENDLY THE
FROM THE LIST OF EVERYONE EACH
INFORMED LABOR CREATED ONE PLAYS
BOTH WORKERS THIS IS THIS IS NOT
EXIST ACTUALLY IT NEEDS THOSE
EACH AND FOR LABOR ACT BASED
BONTA CANNOT HERE TO GET AWAY
WITH IT. IF YOU'RE HARM. THANK
YOU CHANGES MADE AB SIX OUR CALL
I AND YOU WANT AND MAKE AND MAKE
. MORE OF. THE CAL. PROBABLY ON
HOW TO WAIT. THIS HAS BEEN
HEAVILY OF BY THE YOU BUT IS HAS
AFTER THAT NOT THE CARD OF THE
PROVIDES PROBES MY THE FOCUS
THANK YOU FOR A LARGE. I'VE
WORKED WITH THOUSANDS OF TRAFFIC
VICTIMS IN MY YEARS SURPRISE I
THANK IN THE CREATIVE AND HARM
WAYS THAT. EXPLOIT AND ABUSE.
TRAPPERS WE ARE GOVERNMENT
SYSTEM REGULATORY IS REAGANESQUE
BUSINESS ON OUR LACK OF
ATTENTION VULNERABLE YOUR
ESPECIALLY IF YOU ARE ARE
CALIFORNIA MUST BE CREATIVE IN
ITS TO COMBATING TRAFFICKING IN
AND I CAN ONLY BE BY BY FREE X.
NEW ON POLICY. FIFTY FOUR. THIS
THANK YOU FOR DEEP THE TIME TO
DISCUSS WITH THEM ISSUE RIGHT
NOW ALL. THANK YOU IN OUR LAST
ANALYST A- SIMPLY RESEARCH. YEAH
GOOD MORNING EVERY- MY A THANK.
MORE THAT ARE AND I HAVE A
MEMBER OF THE OVER THAT'S WHAT
AS THE CHAIR OF THE COMMISSION
ARE. OF THE CONSIDERED BE A ONE
TO SAY ME ON THE OUTSIDE PROGRAM
WE ARE ALL TWENTY WHICH THE TO
PROVIDE THIS. WHAT IS THE LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE HOOVER COMMISSION
THE COMMISSION IS AN IN BY PART
OVERSIGHT AGENCY CHARGED WITH
MAKING RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATURETHE
IMPROVE THE EFFICIENCY AND
EFFECTIVENESS. OF STATE
GOVERNMENT. IN TWENTY NINETEEN
WE LAW THIS ON THE STREET FIRST
. THE LABOR TRAFFIC. MISSOURI
FORM OF MARTINSVILLE. EXPLOITS
WEAKNESSES WORKERS WILL FORCE.
.ORG KHORCHIN AND OFTEN THE ARE
TRAPPED IN OPPRESSIVE SITUATIONS
WE WERE HONORED DURING IN TWENTY
NINETEEN THAT SENATE PRESIDENT
PRO TEM TONI ATKINS OPENED OUR
FIRST HEARING ON THIS TOPIC IN
SAN DIEGO. I BELIEVE THAT YOU
ALSO HAVE A COPY OF THE SLIDES
AND I WAS SUPPOSED TO USE WHEN I
WAS HAVING TECH ISSUES SO IF YOU
COULD JUST REFER TO IT YOU WILL
HELP OUR FINAL. TESTIMONY I AM
GIVING. SO THE REPORT THAT WE
ISSUED OUR OR OR WE DID
CONTAMINATED IN OUR THREE ARE UP
TO REPORTS AND RECOMMENDATIONS
TO THE GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATURE
THE STRENGTHENED CALIFORNIA'S
RESPONSE. THESE FINEST HEROES
CRIME. TODAY I WILL SHARE WITH
YOU FINDINGS FROM THESE REPORTS
AND THE STEPS CALIFORNIA CAN
TAKE TO BETTER ADDRESS. LABOR
TRAFFICKING. SO WHAT WHAT LABOR
TRAFFICKING. IN CALIFORNIA LOOK
LIKE. THE STATE MADE OLD OF
TRAFFICKING A CRIME BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND FIVE. THINGS THEN STATE
POLICIES FUNDING AND RESOURCES
HAVE LARGELY FOCUSED ON
COMBATING SEX TRAFFICKING
PARTICULARLY OF MINORS LET ME BE
CLEAR THE WORK AGAINST SEX
TRAFFICKING MUST CONTINUE- WE
ALSO MUST DO MORE TO COMBAT
LABOR TRAFFICKING NORTH STATE.
AND ALTHOUGH THERE IS SO MUCH
THAT WE DO NOT KNOW DATA FROM
NATIONAL HEADLINES AND STATE
PROGRAMS GIVE US A LOT OF
INSIGHTS INTO WHERE LABOR
TRAFFICKING IS OCCURRING IN
CALIFORNIA AND WHO IS IMPACTED.
SO WHERE DOES LABOR TRAFFICKING
HAVE BEEN IN OUR STATE.
CALIFORNIA'S MAJOR HARBOURS
AIRPORTS COASTLINES AND
APPROXIMATELY THREE
INTERNATIONAL BORDERS MAKE OUR
STATE ALL ARTICULATED WEARABLES
HUMAN TRAFFICKING. LABOR
TRAFFICKING OF COURSE IN A VAST
RANGE OF INDUSTRIES INCLUDING
DOMESTIC WORK TRAVELING SALES
AND WE CULTURE RESTAURANTS
BEAUTY AND CONSTRUCTION.
SURVIVORS OF HIS ABUSE SHOW UP
MORE FREQUENTLY IN LOS ANGELES
AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY MORE THAN
OTHER CONDITIONS IN CALIFORNIA.
WHEN I TALK ABOUT THIS
POPULATION WHO ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT. NATIONAL DATA SUGGEST
THAT THERE IS NOT A SINGLE TYPE
OF PERSON WHO FOR. WAS BRAVE A
NEIGHBOR TO MAKING. MORE WORK
BETTER AT PRIME WORKING AGE ARE
EIGHTEEN AND FORTY YEARS OLD
MANY IMMIGRANTS WHO ARE IN
ENTERED THE COUNTRY BELIEVE TO
PERFORM SOME KIND OF TEMPORARY
WORK AND BECOME A AUTHORIZED
USER THEIR TRAFFICKING. STATE
DATA ALSO BUILT THE LABOR
TRAFFICKING SURVIVORS ACCOUNT
FOR ABOUT TWENTY FEET OF THE
MORE THAN FOURTEEN THOUSAND UMAN
TRAFFICKING SURVIVORS RECEIVE
STATE ASSISTANCE FROM TWENTY
SIXTEEN TO TWENTY NINETEEN. THIS
INCLUDES MEN AND WOMEN AND
CHILDREN AND ADULTS INDIVIDUALS
FROM A VARIETY OF ETHNIC
BACKGROUNDS ENGLISH AND NON
ENGLISH SPEAKERS AS WELL AS
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES.
SO WHAT ARE SOME OF THE PROBLEMS
AND SOLUTIONS THAT ARE THE
COMMISSION'S REPORT HIGHLIGHTED
. ONE IT IS CRITICAL THAT
CALIFORNIA TAKE ACTION TO COMBAT
LABOR TRAFFICKING JUST AS
AGGRESSIVELY AS IT COMBATS SEX
TRAFFICKING. THERE'S A NEXUS
BETWEEN THE TWO. HOWEVER THERE
ARE SEVERAL BARRIERS THAT
PREVENT CALIFORNIA FROM DOING SO
AND LET ME OUTLINED SOME OF
THOSE KEY CHALLENGES THAT WE
IDENTIFIED AS WELL AS THE
SOLUTIONS YOU RECOMMEND. PROBLEM
NUMBER ONE CALIFORNIA LACKS
LEADERSHIP AROUND ANTI
TRAFFICKING ACTIVITIES. FIRST WE
FOUND THE CALIFORNIA LACKS A
COORDINATED STRATEGY TO TARGET
NEWMAN TRAFFICKING STATEWIDE LET
ALONE TO PURSUE LABOR
TRAFFICKING SPECIFICALLY.
ORDINATING BODY LEAVITT LED BY
THE STATE DEPARTMENT THE STATE'S
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
COMBATS CHILD SEX TRAFFICKING
BUT NO OTHER RECORDED NIGHT
COORDINATING BODY EXISTS AT THE
STATE LEVEL. TWO STATE AGENCIES
THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING AS WELL
AS THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
HAVE A ROLE IN PROSECUTING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING FOR BOTH CIVIL AND
CRIMINAL OFFENSES. LOOKING TO
OTHER STATES WE FOUND THAT LAKE
COUNTY FOR NOW MOST FOCUSED ON
SEX TRAFFICKING PARTICULARLY
EXCEPT FOR THE STATE OF COLORADO
LET'S NOT MORTALS A STATEWIDE
MODEL THE CALIFORNIA CUT COULD
ACTUALLY LOOK TO OR OR OR ARE
EXAMINED. ALSO RECOMMENDATIONS
ACCORDED CALIFORNIA STATE
RESPONDS. PROVIDES THE
LEADERSHIP ARE ON TRAFFICKING WE
RECOMMEND TO PROVIDE STATE
LEADERSHIP BROWN TRAFFICKING WE
RECOMMEND THAT CALIFORNIA FORM
AND I'M THANK YOU MUCH
TRAFFICKING COUNCIL TO
COORDINATE EFFORTS OF GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES AND NGOS ARE ON
FIGHTING ALL FORMS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. FOR THREE PATIENTS
SHOULD BE BROADBAND AND INCLUDE
REPRESENTATIVES OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICE AGENCIES ADVOCATES
SURVIVORS AND OTHERS. THE GOAL
DISCUSS WE SHOULD BE TO RAISE
PUBLIC AWARENESS ABOUT
TRAFFICKING COLLECTING DATA
ABOUT WHERE AND HOW TRAFFICKING
OCCURS IN THE STATE. IMPROVE
TRAINING. DEVELOP STANDARDIZED
WHICH TRAFFICKING
AND CATALOG AND ASSESS RESOURCES
THAT ARE AVAILABLE FOR SURVIVORS
SO THAT THEY ARE EASILY
ACCESSIBLE. PROBLEM NUMBER TWO
LABOR TRAFFICKING OFTEN GOES
UNDETECTED. WE FOUND THAT LABOR
TRAFFICKING IS OFTEN HARD TO
IDENTIFY AND THUS FREQUENTLY
GOES UNDETECTED IT CAN BE HIDDEN
IN PLAIN SIGHT YOU'VE HEARD OF
SOME OF THE TESTIMONY EARLIER
OFTEN WITHIN BUSINESSES OR
INDUSTRIES THAT MIGHT OTHERWISE
BE LEGITIMATE BECAUSE THIS
OCCURS IN ALMOST MANY OF THE
INDUSTRIES THAT I HAVE NOTED BOB
. NO WONDER SOME OF THE
OBSTACLES TO FINDING LABOR
TRAFFICKING IN CALIFORNIA. OUR
RESEARCH HIGHLIGHTS SEVERAL
OBSTACLES THAT MAKE IT DIFFICULT
TO IDENTIFY LABOR TRAFFICKING
CASES. A VARIETY OF GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS COULD ENCOUNTER LABOR
TRAFFICKING IN THE COURSE OF
THEIR DAY TO DAY WORK BURKE BUT
NO STATE AGENCY HAS A MANDATE TO
ACTUALLY LOOK FOR LABOR
TRAFFICKING. TO LOOK FOR
SPECIFIC INDICATORS OF
TRAFFICKING. INVESTIGATORS OFTEN
STUMBLE ACROSS THE EVIDENCE BUT
THEY ARE NOT PROACTIVE IN
LOOKING FOR IT. MOST GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS HAVE NOT RECEIVED ANY
TO IDENTIFY LABOR TRAFFICKING OR
HOW TO REPORT ANY FINDINGS.
PURSUING THESE CASES REQUIRES
COORDINATION AMONG AGENCIES
INVOLVED LABOR RIGHTS LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND MANY OTHER
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES WHAT
OFTENTIMES WORK IS DONE IN
CYCLES OFTEN WITH DISCONNECT
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND YOU
ARE OFFICIALS AS WELL AS OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS. THE ONLY THE
DEPARTMENT YOUTH THE REPORT
ABUSES OFTEN FALLS AND WILL
NOTABLE WORKERS WHO ARE
LEGITIMATELY FEARFUL TO REPORT
ABUSES AND AS A RESULT CASES GO
UNREPORTED. WHAT ARE SOME OF OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS TO UNCOVER THIS
HIDDEN CRIME. WE RECOMMEND
SEVERAL STEPS FOR THE STATE TO
INCREASE ITS FIRST ONE COVER
LABOR TRAFFICKING. CALIFORNIA
SHOULD TRAIN STATE INVESTIGATORS
AND OTHER EMPLOYERS WHO INTERACT
WITH HIGH RISK POPULATIONS TO
RECOGNIZE THE WARNING SIGNS OF
LABOR TRAFFICKING AND RESPOND
APPROPRIATELY. WE MUST RAPIDLY
USE DATA AND TECHNOLOGY TO
SEARCH FOR ANOMALIES THAT MIGHT
SUGGEST THE PRESENCE OF LABOR
TRAFFICKING IN CERTAIN
BUSINESSES INDUSTRIES OR
REGIONS. WE SHOULD INCREASE
AWARENESS OF ALL FORMS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING THROUGH PUBLIC
AWARENESS AND OUTREACH CAMPAIGNS
. PROBLEM NUMBER THREE ARE
VARIOUS BARRIERS THAT MAKE IT
DIFFICULT FOR SURVIVORS THE AXIS
HELP. WHEN I HAD A NUMBER OF
CHALLENGES THAT MAKE IT
DIFFICULT FOR SUCH SURVIVORS TO
GET THE HELP THAT THEY NEED.
WHAT ARE SOME OF THOSE.
SURVIVORS NEED A RANGE OF
SUPPORTS BUT WE DON'T KNOW
ENOUGH ABOUT THE SPECIFIC NEEDS
OF LABOR TRAFFICKING SURVIVORS
TO SAY WHICH PROGRAMS ARE MOST
EFFECTIVE AND HOW THEIR BEST
DELIVERED. ADDITIONALLY
SURVIVORS QUALIFY FOR VARIOUS
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES BUT HELP
ISN'T ALWAYS EASY TO FIND THERE
IS NO ONE STOP SHOP TO FIND
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT IS
AVAILABLE STATEWIDE. FOR THIS
WE'D LIKE TO RECOMMEND THE
FOLLOWING. TRACKS SERVICE
PROVISION TO LABOR TRAFFICKING
SURVIVORS SO WE CAN. BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE NEEDS AND
DEMOGRAPHICS OF THIS POPULATION
. RESEARCH ANYBODY WOULD
ADVOCACY OF SERVICE PROGRAMS AND
CREATE A USER FRIENDLY DIRECTORY
OF ALL RESOURCES FOR TRAFFICKING
SURVIVORS TO MAKE IT EASIER TO
FIND HELP. LASTLY WE FOUND THE
PROSECUTION'S FOR LABOR
TRAFFICKING ARE RARE WE KNOW
THAT AT THE VERY LEAST HUNDREDS
OF LABOR TRAFFICKING SURVIVORS
SEEK HELP OUR NEWLY IN
CALIFORNIA BUT ON AVERAGE THERE
ARE LESS THAN THIRTY CONVICTIONS
FOR LABOR TRAFFICKING EACH YEAR.
IN THE STATE. SO WISELY WE'RE
TALKING DIFFICULT TO PROSECUTE
YOU ASK LABOR TRAFFICKING IS
DIFFICULT TO PROSECUTE FOR A
NUMBER OF REASONS. WHY ANY
SURVIVORS MAY BE RELUCTANT TO
PARTICIPATE AND PROSECUTIONS FOR
FEAR ALL BROUGH TRAUMATIZING
ATION. FOR YOUR OUR OUR DISTRUST
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT OR JUST
SIMPLY WANTING TO MOVE ON FROM
THE REVIEWS. THE INVESTIGATIONS
ARE ESPECIALLY COSTLY TIME
CONSUMING AND RESOURCE
INTENSIVE. WE CAN REQUIRE
INVOLVEMENT OF SPECIALIZED
INVESTIGATORS. AS WELL AS
RESEARCHING NEW ERA AREAS OF LAW
. THE CRIME CAN ALSO OCCUR EVEN
WHEN THERE IS NO EVIDENCE OF
PHYSICAL FORCE OR VIOLENCE
MAKING IT DIFFICULT TO PROVE IN
COURT. WE DON'T USE SEVEN
ENFORCEMENT ENOUGH IN EITHER
LOCAL OR STATE COURTS AT THE
STATE LEVEL THE DEPARTMENT OF
FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING WAS
AUTHORIZED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN TO
PROSECUTE SIMPLE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING COMPLAINTS BUT THERE
HAVE BEEN NO PROSECUTIONS TO
DATE. LOS ANGELES CITY ATTORNEY
AND OTHERS JURISDICTIONS ARE
EXPERIMENTING WITH USING CIVIL
ACTION TO GO AFTER TRAFFICKERS.
THIS IS VERY NOBODY WORK BUT AT
THE STATE WE DON'T TRACK WITH
AND WE HAVEN'T EXPLORED THIS
WIDELY ENOUGH. THE STATE ALSO
LACKS RESOURCES LIKE PUBLISHED
CASE LAW AND TRAINING FOR
PROSECUTION PROSECUTORS THE
STATE LAWS TO PURSUE LABOR
TRAFFICKING CASES. WHILE THERE
ARE RESOURCES FOR HOW TO USE
STATE LAWS TO GO AFTER SEX
TRAFFICKING CASES THERE IS NO
CLARITY IN RESOURCES FOR LABOR
TRAFFICKING CASES. WE DON'T HAVE
FORMAL AGREEMENTS OR OTHER
INFORMATION SHARING AGREEMENTS
IN PLACE FOSTER ONGOING
COORDINATION AMONG RELEVANT
AGENCIES. FINALLY WHAT ARE SOME
OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS TO BRING
TRAFFICKERS TO JUSTICE. WHAT IS
EMPOWERING THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS THE NEED
EFFORTS TO PURSUE LABOR
TRAFFICKING CASES ALONGSIDE
OTHER WORK TO COMBAT THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY. CREATING
STANDARDIZED MEANS FOR AGENCIES
TO TRACK REFERRALS OR COMPLAINTS
SHARE INFORMATION AND PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO CASES.
WE CAN TRACK HOW MANY AND WHAT
TYPES OF LABOR TRAFFICKING CASES
ARE BROUGHT FORWARD AND STUDY
OUTCOMES OF THESE CASES THE
IDENTIFY BEST PRACTICES. WE CAN
ALSO ENHANCE TRAINING SO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND COURT PERSONNEL
KNOW HOW TO USE STATE LAWS TO
COMBAT LABOR TRAFFICKING. THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS ONCE IMPLEMENTED
WILL HELP ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA
TAKE STRONGER ACTIONS TO DETECT
LABOR TRAFFICKING. HELP
SURVIVORS AND PROSECUTE
PERPETRATORS THE COMMISSION
WOULD BE HAPPY TO PROVIDE YOU
WITH A DETAILED- THREE REPORTS
THAT WE DID A FEW YEARS AGO IF
IT'LL HELP GIVE MORE DETAIL ON
THE TESTIMONY THAT I PROVIDED.
THANK YOU ARE MEDICARE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND I AM HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU COMMISSIONER- LOUISA.
DR CORK I'VE BEEN TOLD YOU HAVE
PERFECT WAY TO THE CHECK CAME
BACK HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE
CHAIR SO SHE COULD GO TO ANOTHER
MEMBER. OKAY THANK YOU. IS THERE
SOMEONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
YES GO AHEAD SIR. FIRST AND
FOREMOST I WANT TO THANK ALL OF
THE PANELISTS TODAY WE HAVE COME
AND SHARE YOUR- YOUR EXPERTISE
THE SENATE GENENTECH TRAFFICKING
POLICY INITIATIVE THAT. WILL LAW
SCHOOL AS AN EXAMPLE FOR THE
ENTIRE STATE IN THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY ON HOW TO LOOK AT ALL OF
THESE ISSUES IN A IN A HOLISTIC
SENSE. I MISS GRIFFITH IN
PARTICULAR THANK YOU FOR COMING
IN PERSON. I AM TESTIFYING SO
POWERFULLY IN REMINDING US THAT.
ADDRESSING THE HARM CAUSED BY
EXPLOITATION WITH SYSTEMS THAT
ARE ROOTED IN HARM AND
EXPLOITATION MIGHT ALSO BE
COUNTER TO THE BROADER GOALS. A
WELLBEING DETERRENCE. AND
ACCOUNTABILITY- YOU ALSO POINT
OUT A NUMBER OF WAYS THAT THE
STATE HAS PERSONALLY FAILED YOU
AND I APOLOGIZE. FOR THOSE
BETWEEN YOUR TESTIMONY AND THE
TESTIMONY FROM THE VICTIMS
COMPENSATION FUND I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK. THAT WE
CAN DO I'M SHOCKED I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THE REST THE COMMITTEE TO
HEAR THAT ONLY FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTY APPLICANTS. HAVE APPLIED
TO THE VICTIMS COMPENSATION
FUND- AND THAT THERE'S THIS
MISMATCH BETWEEN TRAFFICKING AND
OTHER DEFINITIONS AND POLICE
REPORT I THINK IT'S SOMETHING WE
NEED TO LOOK AT HIM PROBABLY
LOOK AT URGENTLY- AND SO MY-
QUESTION IS LESS OF A QUESTION.
AND MORE OF A COMMENT OF
GRATITUDE AND THANK YOU FOR ALL
OF THE INSIGHT THAT YOU ALL HERE
TODAY. THE NO BELIEVE MR.
QUESTION WAS FOR ME. YES MISTER
CHAIR SO WE HEARD OUTSTANDING-
TESTIMONY BOTH FROM THE
GENTLEMAN HERE AND FROM THIS
BOOZER AND OTHERS ON LABOR
TRAFFICKING. AS I SAID IT'S 80%
ROUGHLY NOBODY REALLY KNOWS AN
EXACT NUMBER BUT IT'S 80% OF THE
PROBLEM. NOT THE MOST AMUSING DE
UNIONIZING PART BUT CERTAINLY A
VERY LARGE PART. AND MY QUESTION
FOR YOU AND COMMITTEE STAFF IS
OF THE VARIOUS RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT WERE GETTING. WHICH OF THEM
ARE BUDGET AT WHICH OF THEM ARE
WOULD BE BEST SOLVED BY A BUDGET
ASK. WHICH WOULD BE BEST SOLVED
BY LEGISLATION. WHICH WOULD BE
BEST SOLVED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION TAKING A
DIFFERENT APPROACH. ALL ON THE
ADMINISTRATION SIDE- WE COULD
CERTAINLY PASS A RESOLUTION
ASKING THEM TO DO SOMETHING OF
COURSE LEGISLATION I WOULD BE
GLAD CO AUTHOR AUTHOR. AND
PERHAPS WE AS A GROUP COULD GET
TOGETHER WITH BUDGET SUB FIVE
THE GROUP THAT WORKS WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT ALTHOUGH. IT'S THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS PERHAPS. BEST TO GET
AWAY FROM BUDGET SUB FIVE AND
WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS. ON THIS
LABOR TRAFFICKING ISSUE WHICH IS
A MUCH HARDER PROBLEM. AND MUCH
WERE WE HAVEN'T PUT THE
RESOURCES IN BOTH WHICH IS
CAUSING SO MUCH PAIN. SO THAT IS
MY QUESTION TO YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND TO YOUR STAFF. AND PERHAPS
IF YOU COULD GET BACK TO- IF
YOU'RE WILLING TO GET BACK TO
OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS. AND TALK
ABOUT NEXT STEPS I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING WE'RE ALL OF US. ARE
COULD GET TOGETHER AND PROVIDE A
CAT PATH FORWARD BECAUSE OF THE
GREAT. VALUE THAT WE'VE HEARD
TODAY YES- IN A IN A REASON WE
HAVE THESE HEARINGS IS SO THAT
WE CAN LEARN MORE A GUY THE FOR
ME- I DIDN'T KNOW HOW SERIOUS
THE PROBLEM OF LABOR.
TRAFFICKING WHAT. IS RIGHT NOW
AND SO- OBVIOUSLY WE NEED TO
WE'VE SEEN SOME BILLS I THINK
SOME FROM LORETTA GONZALEZ WHO
WAS A FORMER COLLEAGUE OF OURS.
PACIFIC WE NEED TO STEP UP. WHAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING IN THE PAST. I
THINK WE ALSO NEED TO DO ON ALL
THREE LEVELS IN A STRAIGHT OF.
LEGISLATION AND BUDGET- ONE
WORKING WITH ADMINISTRATION SO
THEY CAN TIGHTEN UP THE
EFFICIENCY AND EFFECTIVENESS OF
THE- THE OPERATING ORGANIZATION
THAT'S IN PLACE RIGHT NOW. SO WE
CAN DO A BETTER JOB WHILE
WORKING WITH INDIVIDUALS. AND
I'LL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE
YESTERDAY WAS BUDGET SUB FIVE.
AND WE TALKED ABOUT THE VICTIMS
COMPENSATION BOARD. AND I
MENTIONED- ABOUT VICTIMS PEOPLE
WHO ARE VICTIMS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND WHETHER OR NOT-
LIKE THE END INDIVIDUAL THAT WAS
ON A NO KNOCK WARRANT THAT WAS
KILLED BY POLICE EVEN THOUGH HE
WENT TO THE PERSON THEY WERE
LOOKING FOR HE DIED AS A RESULT
OF. WELL ACCORDING TO THE- HE
WOULD NOT BE. HE OR HIS FAMILY
WOULD NOT BE. ELIGIBLE TO
RECEIVE VICTIMS COMPENSATION
BECAUSE THEY WOULDN'T CATEGORIZE
THAT AS THE CRIME. WE MAY THINK
OR I MAY THINK IT WAS A CRIME
THAT THAT HAPPENED BUT SINCE
IT'S NOT A CRIME IN SOME WAYS
IT'S A CASUALTY OF WAR CAVITY
THAT HAPPEN IS A MISTAKE SAID
UNFORTUNATE ACCIDENT AND ALL OF
THAT. BUT THAT FAMILY COULDN'T
GET FUNERAL EXPENSES PAID THEY
COULD GET A MENTAL HEALTH
BECAUSE IT IS NOT CTEGORIZED AS
A CRIME AND SO WE PROBABLY NEED
TO LOOK AT LEGISLATION SO THAT
THE VICTIMS COMPENSATION BOARD
CAN ADDRESS. OF SOME OF THE
THINGS YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
MAYBE FILL THOSE LOOPHOLES AND
THAT WAS IN BUDGET YESTERDAY
LITERALLY YESTERDAY WE HAD THAT
DISCUSSION. AND SO YOU'RE RIGHT
WE NEED TO BRING THEM BRING
DEMAND SO IT IS A IT IS A- THREE
PRONG. EFFORT AND WE NEED IT THE
OTHER THING WE'VE GOT TO STOP
WORKING IN SILOS AND START
TALKING TO EACH OTHER. ON THE
SAME WAY WITH- MATURING THAT.
DOJ AND OTHERS WHO ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS THAT- IT'S
NOT JUST LAW ENFORCEMENT IS NOT
JUST. REHABILITATION AND GETTING
TO THE ROOT CAUSES OF TRAUMA AND
EVERYTHING IS NOT JUST THAT IT'S
NOT JUST MAKING SURE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE WE CREATE- WILL
ADDRESS EVERYTHING SO- I. I
WOULD HAVE THAT'S PART OF WHY WE
PUT THIS TOGETHER. SO WE COULD
GET DIRECTION OR AT LEAST HAVE
AN IDEA OF HOW WE CAN SOLVE THIS
AT THE END OF THE DAY I'M TIRED
OF TALKING ABOUT THE PROBLEM. A
LONG TALK ABOUT SOLUTIONS AND
FINALLY WORK ON THINGS. THAT WE
CAN ACTUALLY DO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. RESPOND TO. AT
FIRST I ALSO WANTED TO THANK MRS
GRIFFITH FOR YOUR INCREDIBLY
POWERFUL TESTIMONY AT A
PARTICULARLY IN TWO ASPECTS OF
IT ONE AT YOUR DESCRIPTION OF
THE WAY IN WHICH OUR PERSONAL
SYSTEM CONTINUES TO RE HARMON
NOT REALLY CREATE THE KIND OF
REHABILITATIVE OPPORTUNITIES
THAT PEOPLE NEED I THINK THAT
YOUR PARTICULAR- DESCRIPTION OF
THE WAY IN WHICH YOU AS SOMEBODY
WHO IS HAS BEEN A VICTIM OF
ASSAULT. ALSO HAD TO BE
SUBJECTED TO A SYSTEM THAT
CONTINUE TO ASSAULT YOU- AND-
ONE THING THAT THAT RACE FOR ME
WAS THAT AMOUNT OR QUITE FRANKLY
THE LACK OF RESOURCES THAT WE
HAVE NCDC ARE GOING SPECIFICALLY
TOWARDS REHABILITATIVE CARE AND
TRAUMA INFORMED CARE AND AT
MISTER CHAIR I WOULD LOVE FOR US
TO BE ABLE TO TAKE UP AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY LOOK AT
THE DISTRIBUTION OF DOLLARS THAT
GO TOWARDS IT I WAS TOLD BY ONE
GROUP THAT WE ONLY HAVE ABOUT
ONE PERCENT. OF THE DOLLARS IN
CDC ARE GOING TOWARDS
REHABILITATION REHABILITATE
CAROUSEL THAT'S SOMETHING I
THINK THAT WE NEED TO LOOK INTO-
WHEN WOULD SUPPORT YOU IN IN
DOING THAT- AND THE SECOND ISSUE
IS THAT I WANTED TO JUST REYES
WAS AT THANK YOU TO MR VIJAY
REZA- FOR- MAKING SURE THAT WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY AYE HE DID
MAKE A SPECIFIC BUDGET ASK A
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR US
TO BE ABLE TO EXPAND THE SCOPE
OF OUR KNOWLEDGE PARTICULAR TO.
LABOR TRAFFICKING AND- AND IT
DOES SEEM TO BE AN AREA AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CORE GRAZED AT
THAT WE CONTINUE TO NOT HAVE
ENOUGH VISIBILITY INTO IN ORDER
TO BE ABLE TO SHAPE THE KINDS OF
SOLUTIONS THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS SO I AM LOOKING FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BOTH. OF THOSE ISSUES.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER. QUESTIONS
CONCERNS OBSERVATIONS. RIGHT THE
LAPTOP THANK ALL THE PANELISTS
THEY CAME IN TODAY THIS THIS IS-
NOT ONLY WAS A GOOD THOUGHT
PROVOKING BUT I THINK IT IT- IT
HELPED US NARROW DOWN SOME
SOLUTIONS THAT WE NEED TO WORK
ON AND WITH THAT I'M GOING TO
MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT. AND- IS
THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE
ROOM I SEE MISTER JOHN LOAL. IT
HERE. WITHIN THE ROOM. IT'S BEEN
A FASCINATING HEARING- GOOD-
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S JOHN
LEVEL- I REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA NARCOTIC OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION AND DON'T BE MISLED
BY THAT APPELLATION BECAUSE WE
ARE ON THE FRONTLINES OF MAJOR
HUMAN TRAFFICKING ACTIVITIES THE
CARTELS IN MEXICO- THERE WAS
RECENTLY- A NEWS- STORY ABOUT IT
ON THE CITY UNIVERSITY ON. HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IS THE SECOND
HIGHEST INCOME STREAM OF THE-
DRUG CARTELS. IT HAS THERE WAS A
NEWS STORY- NOT TOO LONG AGO
WHERE ONE OF THE COMMENTATORS
SAID- GUESS WHAT IT HAS IT'S NOW
MORE THAN KIDNAPPING IT'S NOW
MORE THAN CONTRACT KILLINGS- IT
IS THE SECOND HIGHEST IN WE
HAVE- THE NARCOTIC OFFICERS
HELLO HAVE A LOT OF INTERACTION
WITH THAT- MISTER JONES SAWYER.
MADE AN INTERESTING COMMENT IN
THE- HEARING WHERE HE TALKED
ABOUT- THE COMPARISON OF
ENSLAVEMENT. WITH HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND LABOR
TRAFFICKING I'M ASSUMING- I
THINK THAT LIGHTS A PATH FOR
EVERYONE TO THINK ABOUT LET'S
LOOK AT A RECONSTRUCTION MODEL
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WERE
DONE IN THE WAKE OF THAT- LET'S
LOOK AT FOR HUMAN TRAFFICKING
AND LABOR TRAFFICKING VICTIMS
SOMETHING ALONG THE MODEL OF THE
FREEDMEN'S BUREAU. LET'S
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE IS A ROLE
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT JUST AS
THERE WAS A ROLE FOR UNION
TROOPS DURING RECONSTRUCTION- IN
. LET'S GO BACK AND LOOK AT HOW.
IN SLAVE MEANT WAS DEALT WITH
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IS IN ALL ITS FORMS.
AND LET'S LOOK AT THAT AS WE
DEVELOP ALL MODELS THAT'S ALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH REALLY
ENJOYED HEARING FOUND IT VERY
INFORMATIVE. THE PANELISTS WERE
INCREDIBLE GOOD JOB THANK YOU-
ARE THERE ANY. CAN WE OPEN IT UP
TO EIGHTEEN- AT&T WRITING. OPEN
UP THE MIKE FOR ANY- ANY-
INDIVIDUAL LIKE TO MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT. THANK YOU AND IF SO I
WOULD ASK YOU TO PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD AGAIN IT'S ONE ZERO. IF
YOU HAVE A COMMENT. AND GIVE US
JUST A MOMENT. AGAIN IT'S ONE
ZERO CAPULINA OPENED WE DO HAVE
ONE AND SHE WILL JUST BE A
MOMENT HERE. TO FISH. NEVER HAD
AN OPEN LINE. THIRTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING TWENTY
NUMBER THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
COMMUNITY HEARING MY NAME IS
JAMIE BACK AND THE PRESIDENT AND
MANAGING ATTORNEY OF FREQUENT
PRESS FREE FIVE IS A FOR A
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BASED
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
PROVIDES LEGAL SERVICES YOU CAN
CHECK DRIVERS. I THIRTY FIVE
FIVE YEARS AGO TO ADDRESS THE
UNMET LEGAL NEEDS ATTACKING
SURVIVORS. WE'VE HEARD A LOT
TODAY ABOUT THE FACT THAT
TALKING FOREVER'S CHU OFTEN ARE
CRIMINALIZED. AS A RESULT OF THE
CRIMINALIZATION OF SURVIVORS ONE
OF THE GREATEST REPORT NEEDS OF
OUR CLIENTS IT HELP CLEARING
CRIMINAL RECORDS YOU CAN
CALIFORNIA TAKE A TURN OFF.
EVERY 575% OF OUR DRIVER CLIENTS
HAVE A CRIMINAL RECORD. AS A
RESULT. CRIMINAL RECORD CLEARING
IT OF COURSE SERVICE WE PROVIDE
TO OUR SURVIVORS. SERVERS ALSO
HAVE A HUGE UNMET NEED FOR
SPECIALIZED FAMILY LOST
EVERYTHING. FOR EXAMPLE MANY
HUMAN TRAFFICKING SURVIVORS ARE
MERRY Q. AND HAVE CHILDREN WITH
THEIR TRAFFICKERS AND SEX
BUYERS. WANT TO DRIVERS EIGHT
HUNDRED TRAFFICKERS. I OFTEN TRY
TO TRAP HER THE OFFICE HIKING TO
IF CONTROL OVER SURVIVORS THE
FAMILY LAW LEGAL SYSTEM. ADDRESS
SURVIVORS NEED SPECIALIZED THE
SERVICES HELP UNTANGLE THESE
RELATIONS. ENSURE THAT THEY GAIN
CUSTODY OF THE CHILDREN. THE
THIRD ARE HIGHLY SPECIALIZED AND
SURVIVORS ARE OFTEN UNABLE TO
GET HELP FROM MORE GENERAL LEGAL
SERVICES PROVIDER. IN THE LAST
FIVE FOR THE PRIVATE GROWN FROM
A OF THE- TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN.
DESPITE OUR GROWTH MANY A THIRD
SISTER MY OUTPACES OUR CAPACITY
. RAISING THE NECESSARY FUNDS TO
CONTINUE REPORTER SERVICES IS A
CONSTANT CHALLENGE. RECALL THE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
EXACERBATED THE CHALLENGE YOU TO
THE MANY COMPETING NEEDS FOR
GRANT DONOR AND GOVERNMENT FUNDS
. UNFORTUNATELY AS FAR AS I'M
AWARE THERE'S NOT A FUNDING
STREAM AVAILABLE FOR SPECIALIZED
LEGAL SERVICES FOR HUMAN
TRAFFICKING SURVIVORS THROUGH
CALIFORNIA STATE FUNDS. THE
CURRENT FUNDING PROGRAMS FALL
INTO TWO CATEGORIES THE FIRST IS
LEGAL SERVICES FOR ALL VICTIMS
OF CRIME. THAT FUNDING HAS
ALREADY BEEN ALLOCATED AND WERE
NOT ELIGIBLE TO APPLY. EVEN IF
WE COULD APPLY WE DON'T QUALIFY
BECAUSE WE DON'T SERVE ALL THE
COMPLEX CRIME WE ONLY SERVE TAX
WRITERS. EFFECTING AVAILABLE
FINDING IT FOR COMPREHENSIVE
SOCIAL SERVICES FOR SURVIVORS.
EVERY DEPRIVE OUR PROGRAMS ARE
FOCUSED ON SPECIALIZED LEGAL
SERVICES. SO AS A RESULT WE ONE
OF OUR QUALIFY FOR THIS FUNDING
BECAUSE WE DON'T PROVIDE ALL
WRAPPED AROUND THIRD. AS A
RESULT. THERE'S NO CALIFORNIA
FUNDING AND I'M AWARE OF THAT
SPECIFICALLY- PROVIDE
SPECIALIZED LEGAL SERVICES FOR
TRAFFICKING SURVIVORS. AND YET
ONE OF THE GREATEST NEEDS THAT
SURVIVORS HAVE IN ORDER TO LEAD
THE LIFE OF EXPLOITATION AND THE
THRIVING MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY. OPERATIVE PRIZE IS
REQUESTING THE COMMITTEE
CONSIDERED INCLUDING SPECIALIZED
LEGAL SERVICES IN ANY FUTURE BUT
IT BUDGET ITEMS FOR TRACKING TO
BUY OR- THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME AND AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR CONVENIENCE HEARING. THANK
YOU AT&T OPERATOR- BEFORE I GET
. I WOULD LIKE TO GET OUT OF
HAND I USUALLY DO WHAT NAME AN
ORGANIZATION BUT CAN YOU GIVE ME
AN IDEA HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE ON
THE LINE. I WANT TO SPEAK TO
THEM WE MAY HAVE TO GO BACK TO
OUR- USUAL NAME AN ORGANIZATION
. BUT THERE'S NOT THAT MANY.
WILL GIVE PEOPLE A MINUTE BUT
NOT FIVE MINUTES. YEP CURRENTLY-
JUST WANTING IN QUEUE RIGHT NOW
. ALL RIGHT THIS BILL. OKAY GIVE
ME JUST A MOLD WILL OF GOD GET
THEM OUT OF THEIR LINE OPEN GIVE
ME TO SECOND. YEAH I HAVE A
COUPLE MINUTES NOT A HALF HOUR
OKAY. OKAY. I WENT PARTY'S WITH
AN OPERATOR RIGHT NOW WILL GET
THEIR LINE UP THIS IS CAN RECORD
A LINE NUMBER FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BONUSES ARE NUMBER
SPECIALIST LOTS OF TALK ABOUT
YOUR PHILOSOPHY CINEMA PARTY WHO
ARE ON OUR COMMENTS MADE BY.
EACH TRAFFIC. SEARCH GROUP RIGHT
NOW SURE CALIFORNIA PIZZA SURE.
STOCK QUOTES WE HAVE THE
RESOURCES SO I GOT LUCKY. THANK
YOU MISTER THANK YOU THROW. AND
CURRENTLY NO FOR OUT PARTY THANK
YOU. OKAY IN HEARING ALL OF THE
PUBLIC COMMENT- EVERYONE'S
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS ANSWERED-
WE HAD EXCELLENT PANELISTS-
WOULD GET TO A GERMAN ABOUT A
HALF HOUR AHEAD OF TIME SO WITH
THAT I WOULD JOINT HEARING.